e
e e
I will start by uh welcoming everybody
asking you to please silence your phones
if they have not been yet as a
reminder and um there are a lot of
people to speak on this bill coming up
as our first bill so I wanted to um also
mention that if you you handed in a card
to speak and somebody else has already
said everything that you were going to
say and you don't feel like you want to
say anything it's perfectly okay to just
wave off and say no I'm not going to and
we'll just pass by okay uh don't feel
like you have to get up just because we
call you if you don't have anything to
say at that point um and if you have do
want to speak and haven't handed in a
card yet please fill one in and pass it
Forward um the order that I try to go
through these cards to have uh the after
the prime sponsor introduces we try to
go to the general public who's here on
their time uh and as a courtesy let them
get back on with their day we'll then go
to the department and then any lobbyists
that have been showing up and with that
I will open the public hearing on hb720
prohibiting the importation and sale of
live bait fish from out of
state the chair recognizes Patrick long
the prime
sponsor to introduce the
bill good morning Mr chairman members of
the committee uh I'm Patrick en long aka
the other Pat long uh representing
Hillsboro 26 and I want to start off
with uh a story about my personal
connection to this bill uh so I grew up
in Tennessee and I will confess that I
have never caught a bass or a trout
because I don't have the attention span
uh but what I did catch a lot of in the
first 16 years of my life was Tennessee
shiners uh and I would use them to catch
frogs and was hoping to use the frogs to
catch snakes to freak my grandma out but
unfortunately going back to my short
attention span never succeeded in that
but
um one thing I learned from my uh
catching all these shiners is that they
are an invasive species in several of
the neighboring states and so that
brought home to me our responsibility to
protect
uh our ecology protect our ecosystems
from invasive
species You could argue maybe I should
be cheering on my native Spa States
Wildlife uh taking over new places but I
I don't think that's the responsible
thing to
do so this is a proactive step to
protect our Fisheries from invasive
species and Aquatic diseases before they
become widespread uh costly problems the
importation of bait fish is one of the
most significant Pathways for
introducing invasive species and harmful
pathogens into our Waters these fish
often farmed in States like Aransas are
transported here in water that can carry
microscopic hitchhikers uh plant
fragments invasive larvi uh and Aquatic
diseases but it's not just the water uh
the fish themselves can be invasive
species or can carry harmful pathogens
that threaten our
ecosystems uh New Hampshire does require
permits for Bait fish Imports and those
permits are only granted to suppliers in
states with disease monitoring programs
however uh this approach puts control in
the hands of other states rather than
protecting New Hampshire directly uh
even well-regulated programs only test
for a limited set of known
pathogens uh meaning new or emergency
dise or emerging diseases can still slip
through uh additionally these programs
don't test for a species type so there
is no monitoring for invasive species uh
studies conducted in other states have
found invasive species and harmful
pathogens in The Bait fish trade uh even
when those certification requirements
were
followed uh once invasive species are
introduced they're nearly impossible to
eliminate for example the Asian basket
clam which is already established in New
Hampshire uh has cost us over a billion
dollars in damag
by clogging water systems and disrupting
ecosystems while this bill won't address
species already here it will help
prevent future introductions before they
become the next costly
problem New Hampshire would be joining
other states in taking action Maine
Minnesota Utah Montana Oregon and Alaska
have all implemented similar or stricter
regulations to protect their Fisheries
from invasive species and disease
and two things you'll notice about that
list of states first thing you notice is
probably that this is not all blue
States this is a mix of blue states red
States purple States this is not a part
as an issue it's just about protecting
our Fisheries the second thing you'll
notice uh a lot of the critics of the
bill have claimed that it will destroy
ice fishing in New Hampshire but several
of those States uh Alaska Minnesota
Maine Montana and Idaho
are big ice fishing States and similar
or stricter regulations have not
destroyed ice fishing
there uh to be clear uh so I've
submitted an amendment uh to clarify the
bill and make sure it only applies to
importation from out of state uh and
that it doesn't affect saltwater uh
fishing so this would only
impact uh importations from out of state
does not impact the Harvest or sale of
bait fish within New Hampshire engers
will still be able to use live bait and
local bait shops can uh continue selling
locally har Bait fish harvested Bait
fish uh this is a common sense measure
to protect New Hampshire's Fisheries
outdoor recreation economy and Aquatic
ecosystems and I encourage you all to
support this
Bill thank you um do you have a copy of
that amendment that you
uh had submitted uh I do not have a copy
with me today I emailed you a copy I can
provide another distribute a copy to the
committee but um having a paper copy
would be um good if you can go to the
fourth floor and get some copies made I
can Prov time we exec we would have that
handy thank you I can do that after
lunch if that would work for the
committee that's fine um is anybody have
any
questions representative Harvey thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question so uh you're saying that um
bait shops could still have locally
harvested Bait fish um in their shop
right um so where do they get
those well from the local
waterways oh so they catch them a
followup followup so they are harvesting
those local fish on their own or is
there some place that they purchase them
from that's what's confusing me
uh I am not aware of how they currently
do it but certainly they could make
arrangements to either catch them on
their own or uh contract that workout
the same way that they buy bait fish
from out of state now you just have to
buy from a different supplier okay thank
you any further
questions representative tutor thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question I guess I'm just to go how you
would enforce this I mean how would you
tell a Pittsburgh Shiner from an
Arkansas one
well uh I think you would want to ask a
biologist that there are lots of
different types of shiners but
um the I mean right now there's already
a licensing procedure in place for out
ofate
importations so we know where the fish
are coming
from we know who
is buying uh from out of state
um so I think there's yeah there may be
some difficulty in enforcement but I I
think I think it's like enforcing any
other law you do inspections and you
find out what's going
on representative KH
thank you Mr chairman representative
thank you for taking my questions uh if
I understand right that you mentioned
that uh you for your fishing habit you
didn't use
any uh uh bait the bait we are talking
about but I was wondering what motivated
you to introduce this bill well I
believe in uh protecting our environment
our local ecosystems um and making sure
people can enjoy the great outdoors
thank you
any further questions representative
Durkin thank you Mr speaker thank you
for taking my question so um how many
times uh in the last say 15 years have
we had a report of any uh infected Bait
fish uh in the state whether it's
imported or uh caught local as a native
I not sure about the answer to that
representative and I'm not sure that we
would have a report even if it was
infected uh because we are relying on
the reporting from uh Arkansas's system
or whatever state they're coming
from followup followup and uh part two
of that would be as far as an invasive
species have we had any reports of
whether imported of invasive species or
uh local St uh neighboring states having
any invasive
species um well certainly we've had the
Asian basket Clan demonstrating that
sorry as far as a bait fish so a lot of
the fish that are used
are not native here some of them uh
there's speculation that they couldn't
establish their populations locally
because it's too cold here but uh there
was the same issue with the Asian basket
clam uh initially it was believed that
it couldn't reproduce here because it
was too cold uh and there's ice in the
water too much the year uh so people
didn't take it seriously enough when it
was first found here and now we have a
infestation representative
Fox no okay any other further
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank
you the chair now calls Doug
Rollins you need to come up to the if
you're going to talk thank you
and the button for the microphone is
when the red light goes on it's
on all right thank you um my name is
Doug Rollins um I'm a native to uh the
state of New Hampshire I'm also an Avid
Angler uh Sportsman um and my family is
as well I am a local real estate agent
and I am also a local business business
owner I own the winnisquam bait and
tackle shop on Lake
winnisquam um we
currently um rely heavily on this
business in the winter months as you
know um in The Lakes Region it's a
resort area a lot of the businesses die
down and uh since Co we have a ton of
people moving to the state of New
Hampshire for the lifestyle that we
provide with the sporting of fish
and
whatnot um I think I believe this bill
is very premature if not
ridiculous um we've had several years
and it's been commented there's never
been any indication that there's any
invasive species coming into the state
um we rely heavily on the importation of
smelt and shiners currently um as the
years have gone by several bait shops
have gone out of business
a lot of mom and pop shops have gone out
of business alls you have left of the
Big Bass Pros and whatnot which can't
keep up with the demand of local
fisheries and nor do they understand the
local lakes and ponds and the fish that
uh we rely on um in that um fashion I
also believe that during the winter
months I can speak for myself it could
be upwards to almost 70% of our business
um we have a convenience store as part
of our Bait and Tackle but if we didn't
have the bait fish um importation we
would be very strained on business
during the winter months so for that
reason um I oppose this bill and um I I
don't believe there's any scientific
evidence that shows that um there's a
huge impact because we're bringing
shiners and smel into the state the
fishing game already requires us to be
licensed they know what's coming in we
report the numbers um and I have not
seen any indication or evidence of any
impact of uh any type of an issue
because we do this so that's pretty much
yet for me thank you are there any
questions representative Harvey so you
you might be the person that I should
ask my former question to
um where do you get your locally
harvested bit fish there are um several
well i' say several there's actually
very few uh local Trappers that we rely
on and they're usually young people that
are that have the time or people that
can get out and trap bait and streams
and trap smelt uh they have to have a
license that's uh monitored through the
New Hampshire fishing game and I'm sure
you'll hear about that later um but
there just isn't enough people to
sustain the need I mean you've seen the
amount of people that have moved to the
state of New Hampshire I see it on both
sides because I'm also a real estate
agent we've sold homes to people coming
into they're flooding into this state
for the way of life that we want to
preserve and Bait fish is a huge part of
it um and I think that uh you know you
just don't have enough local Trappers to
sustain like you said an individual
would have to go out trap their own bait
or we rely on a hand full of guys that
trap bait and and it's just not enough
to to cover what we need follow up
follow up so um I'm GNA ask a question
and it's probably going to be obvious
that my husband fishes but I don't um so
but I I'm GNA ask the question anyway so
um is it possible are I I understand
going out and
trapping Bait fish my husband does that
with a no trap and so forth so but is is
it possible to have um Fisheries
that um grow
or um maintain Bait fish for uh stores
like I'm sure that you know U other
states have Farms Fish Farms um that
they could do but obviously we don't
have that here at this point in time I
mean somewhere in the future maybe but
um currently I mean to have it supported
in uh from outside sources or out of
state sources um doesn't seem to be
affecting us greatly as far as any
impact on the waters um and and quite
frankly even if you had Bait fish in the
state that we were trapping how like
this gentleman said how are you going to
monitor and tell what's an invasive
species versus on a Shiner and you're
certainly not going to see something
microscopic that comes in on a fish on
their scales on a Shiner that big um so
I you know I just don't think that it's
impactful enough to even uh have this
bill even move forward at this
time any further
questions representative
Durkin thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so let me
understand this the state of New
Hampshire has no Fisheries that raise
specifically freshwater bait
fish I can't answer that probably the
colonel could answer that the colonel
could answer that
definitely Fisher Chief could y so why
don't you hold that question then until
we have them okay and the other part
about that if they don't I don't know
how the streams are down here but up
north in uh the North country most of
those frams are streams this time of
year are frozen so for somebody to go
out and catch that how are they going to
do that uh is several you're going to
hear from several bait guys here today
from some of the faces I've seen guys
work hard to go out and trap bait and it
is difficult you have to fish through
the ice you have to cut if it's even
allowed in certain areas a lot of our
ponds and lakes have been shut down
because of the low population of bait
fish in some areas um but yeah like you
said there as far as I know there isn't
a an area to get bait fish locally that
would sustain the the supply that we
need followup follow up so um also let
me understand that this time of the year
or if there are no Fisheries in New
Hampshire that are raising those that
type of bait that you would rely solely
on Native
CAU at this time of the year
correct representative KH thank you Mr
chairman and thank you sir for taking my
question uh
supply and demand you know the if Supply
is less you know demand is there you
know what happens the prices goes up
please tell us that if this bill goes in
implementing situation what is going to
happen what kind of price we looking for
and you know what what is going to
happen we've already seen a massive
increase in the price of bait fish um I
can't speak for going back into the
early 40s or 50 but I know right now
currently a dozen of smelt uh one smelt
is a dollar or more um we can buy it
wholesale for half that price and we're
selling a a dozen uh smelt for $14 a
dozen um so and it's because of supply
and demand we can't even get it from out
of state um in numbers enough to sustain
when we have fishing Derby's we just got
done with the Meredith fishing derby and
I I know there's several bait dealers
behind me that we ran out and we barely
had enough to support the fishermen for
the deres so like I said we need to rely
on out estate importation of bait
heavily right
now representative
Harvey um so this might be another one
of my questions but that's okay um I
know I went fishing I didn't go fishing
I went with my husband while he fished
on rangley Lake the smelt could not be
alive when he fished and the guide
actually killed the smelt in front of
him to make sure that we knew it was
dead do does that happen a lot because
I'm thinking if the bait fish is not
alive then it can't produce an invasive
species is is that common that you fish
with a dead we we don't current we don't
have a a dead bait law um for smelt and
shiners it's live bait um you can't bait
a treble hook and there's some other
laws but that doesn't affect whether
it's alive or dead um we use live
bait any further
questions seeing none thank you so much
for your
testimony chair will now call Wayne Hall
even my name is Wayne Hall owner of WH
Sports coner New Hampshire I've been a
bait dealer for 46 years
um AJ they spoke very very well there's
nothing I can add to that with the
exception of I think what we really
would need to worry about is if we do
all start trapping what's going to
happen happen to the infrastructure or a
bait fish for a predator fish when the
source is depleted what
happens okay if there's no way if we
take take take take take take take okay
we can all trap we could all probably
find time we could hire people and stuff
like that what happens to the natural
resource when your Predator fish don't
have anything to
eat we've actually seen some over
fishing happen and the colonel can
probably say in two or three lakes and
rivers used to have a beautiful run of
rainbow smell you used to dip some up
and get them for in the spring and have
them for a snack and stuff like that you
know which they are at a the rainbow
smell and now they're clean and there's
no more smell so what happens I mean
that would be my biggest thing um and I
do believe and the colonel again could
answer this that all the tanks that we
buy our fish from have to be
inspected they can't just import fish
from Joe's place down in t uh down in uh
Tennessee or Arkansas and not have him I
think does the water have to be tested
Colonel but you know there's a lot
there's they just can't import fish
without a certain amount of testing and
stuff like that this would severely
detriment because I am the sole owner of
WH
Sports so there's no way I can go out
and trust this a bill like this would AB
absolutely put us right out of business
there be no there's no way you know um
but like I said my biggest concern would
be the natural resources what what what
would this do to our natural
resources thank you any
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony
today chair calls Rebecca meren
hi my name is Rebecca meren um I have
two bait shops one in Barnstead and one
in Meredith um we opened our first bait
shop about 15 years ago um this bill
would definitely um do damage to our
business I have my trapping license my
son has his trapping license my husband
has his trapping license when we first
started we were all trapping we can not
trap enough to keep up with the demand
for our stores there's no way it's
impossible even with having other people
trap for us which we have had um and
I'll be I've been out with my son 8:00
at night pulling traps and you know
trying to help um and it's it's too much
there's no way we could trap enough to
meet up with the demand and I don't
believe it would only affect us as bait
shop owners but people travel from all
over to fish in New Hampshire and
they're getting they're renting h hotels
they're getting airbnbs they're going to
restaurants they're going to gift shops
anybody that relies on tourism will also
be affected by this um so I I believe
it's going to have a huge impact if we
do that and I know every time we get a
delivery we have a paper handed to us
with certification that they are disease
free thank you questions representative
KH thank you Mr chairman and thank you m
Rea for taking my question um you being
in the business can you tell us
any beop owner supports this bill I
don't know of a single bait shop owner
that would support this Bill thank you
any other
questions seeing none thank you so much
for your
testimony chair now calls Diane Timmons
and Matthew Pon from fishing game
yeah hi Mr chairman thank you everyone
for letting us present this testimony to
you my name is Diane Timmons I'm the
Inland Fisheries division
Chief and this is Matt Pearson our fish
habitat
biologist fish health biologist sorry
and
um we are going to speak a little bit
twofold I'm going to speak on the
biological and economic impacts and Matt
is going to speak about the permitting
aspects and fish health related
impacts chair Spain members of the
committee thank you for the opportunity
to provide you with testimony my name is
Matthew Pierson I'm the fish uh fish
hatchery biologist for New Hampshire
fishing game mitigating risks associated
with finfish movements cross state lines
is very important subject that the New
Hampshire fishing game department has
already taken great steps to
address our current rules and
regulations governing Bait fish
importations have not only provided a
robust umbrella of protection but will
continue to provide that protection the
current set of rules are located in FIS
section 400 FIS 500 section FIS 800
section and FIS 1100 section
specifically the testing standards
stated in FIS
80309 which were developed by the
American fishery Society fish health
section that group consists of the fish
health pathologist from across the US
the AFS Blue Book standards are the
official testing protocol approved by
Hua the war world Organization for
Animal Health it is utilized by us Fish
and Wildlife and
apys some may think that regulatory
Authority occurs in other states with
the fish health testing but that is
actually incorrect I personally review
the results of all the fish health
testing that comes into this state and
on top of that I ALS as part of the
observations I'm also in charge of
assessing the geographic risk of where
these fish are coming in the facility
setup the best management practice plans
of the facility
and their uh vertically integrated
biocurity
plans to our knowledge and to our
understanding this bill was proposed
with no specific incident of bait fish
being directly linked to an introduction
of a new pathogen or invasive species
this actually more commonly occurs in
incidences where in the US where illegal
release of ornamental fish from personal
fish tanks
occur but we already have that addressed
in FIS
8051b under prohibited species
release thank you everyone um so as far
as the impacts there are also beyond the
testing if this was approved there are
definitely going to be impacts related
to the economy as you've previously
heard as well as biological biological
impacts to our state Fisheries So
currently we are um going through this
process regulatory to allow clean native
fish species into the state we do not
allow non-native species that's really
important to note because the idea of
invasives through this method is not an
option we only allow native species they
are ided they are
tested so if this was allowed um
approved to go through the sheer numbers
alone so bait dealers right now are
currently importing about 800,000 and
900,000 Bait fish into the state
annually and as you've heard taking
those numbers from our natural water
bodies within State could absolutely be
detrimental to the biological component
of the
fishery the the other aspect is that um
it would impact our angling public so as
a result Anglers would either have to
catch their own bait or um it could
actually result in illegal bait coming
across state lines where um folks are
bringing in bait from other states that
are close to them and they're not
getting a health certificate or or a
permit and so that absolutely could lead
to um problematic invasive species and
disease uh
pathogen as well as they could also not
fish which gets into the impact of us
because of course our license sales are
our primary source of funding and those
license sales would go down if Anglers
were no longer
fishing so in our economy um someone had
mentioned we sell about 50,000 licenses
annually that brings about $6.2 million
in Revenue to us as well as contributes
about 338 million um dollars to the
economy of New
Hampshire as the gentleman previously
mentioned with hotels and the um lady as
well with hotels and various visitors
and Anglers from other
areas so again um for Bait fish
retailers this is part of their business
and of course if their businesses go out
then so does my opportunity for Anglers
potential opportunity for Anglers to go
fishing it's all directly related it's a
big giant Circle and as far as this goes
the purpose of the build the purpose of
the introduction of this was for to
prevent non-native species and promote
Fisheries in New Hampshire and we think
e economically it would not promote
fishing and um biologically it would not
promote Anglers to go fishing with
without proper bait and it would
absolutely have an impact to our wild
waterways so ID Fish ID is definitely an
issue if folks don't know what the
species are in the water body they have
no idea if it's an invasive or not and
we have tons of native minnows and there
are also lots of other minnows in other
areas other states that are not native
to here so folks would not necessarily
know what they're dealing with if
they're out on their own as well as the
fact that we do not have any instate
testing for those folks that are pulling
bait from our natural Waters so we would
not have any recollection or knowledge
or ability to monitor um the fish health
in those waterways as well as um how how
many are being
harvested the other aspect is the um
poor fishing condition of the if you
take away the food chain you're going to
have issues with our fish health and
fish condition in those particular
waterways as you've heard there's a lot
of bait fish that are being imported and
if we were to take that bottom of the
food chain in our own water bodies we
would absolutely potentially have an
impact to our Fisheries which would then
again impact our anger
opportunity and with that I just want to
make sure that um I just reiterate again
we do not our testing currently
prohibits the import of non-native
species it prohibits the import of
unclean fish from unclean facilities and
we do not have testing within state from
those fish that are harvested and again
ID and biological impact would be
prominent
would you please um go over the fiscal
note that you just delivered to the
committee today sure so um attached in
your packet is our testimony both Matt
and myself as well as the fiscal note
and I apologize for not getting that in
earlier um our legal coordinator has
been out on personal illness and
unfortunately this was one of the fiscal
notes that was missed so um it's
attached in your packet I will um get
that to you as well electronically but
in that fiscal note it identifies our
license component and as well as the um
Bait fish reala retailers um information
for the last 3 years as well as the
economic
impact and what was that economic impact
if you could just give us an overview
real quick sure so in 2022 retailers
imported about 800 sorry excuse me 900
,000 Bait fish in 2023 and 24 they
imported about
800,000 and that equaled in their um
Revenue to about
$800,000 that would be lost um to the
state and again that could result in
closure of shops which of course would
then lead to our decline in license
sales so we sell again about 150,000
licenses a year which is roughly $6.2
million in Revenue to fishing game and
again 3.8 million to the New Hampshire
economy thank you any questions Repcon I
saw your hand several times while I was
still asking questions you can go first
I I apologize I'm
sorry thank you Mr chairman uh my
question is if you please uh explain to
me that uh if this industry is highly
regulated uh i' like to know that uh
when you when somebody Imports
those bait and also somebody catches
those baits two separate way how you
regulate so are you talking about the
testing testing
yes so the permitting a bait dealer has
a bait dealer's license they are allowed
to fill out an importation permit with
that importation permit they have to
request the fish health certificate
testing so that includes bacteriology
ver olog parasitology and molecular
Diagnostics as the backing to prove that
these fish are negative for the specific
path pathogens we are looking at from
there they send them to me and in New
Hampshire you are required to have three
consecutive years of testing clean
before we would even approve it once I
have that then I go through and go and
look at the facility making sure they're
on wellwater they're not taking in you
know possible water from you know the
Mississippi River or something where
we're going to have issues with invasive
species also two with that in five FIS
50207 specifically states that whatever
state these fish are coming from has to
have invasive species monitoring program
which is something I go over right there
to make sure that we're not looking at
this this Huck area where these Bait
fish might come from it's infested with
you know Asian carp or something because
we don't want that possible introduction
so from there if you get through all
those testing and my requirements too
that's when we allow the importation to
occur and the importation has to be
delivered directly to the
source follow up Mr chairman follow up
can you tell us the native bait how you
regul it native bait we only allow
golden shiners to be imported those are
mainly come from Arkansas aphis does the
testing on them smelt from
Maine and because main has very similar
species as us and that's it we don't
allow Fathead minnows or any other
invasive species to come in so on the
reporting form you have to specify
exactly which species of fish is coming
in represented
Harvey thank you uh Mr chair um so I
heard the sponsor of the bill I'm I'm
just confused because I heard the
sponsor of the bill testify that we are
at the mercy of outof State Testing but
yet I'm hearing that you are pre um
presenting a lot of testing so um can
you address that I think you're talking
about the authority to import the ba the
testing is done call it from Arkansas
where someone wants to import Arkansas
golden shiners from
farmx Farm X gets aist or an approved
testing Source through AFS has to go by
our
guidelines once they have that they send
me everything and I can approve that I'm
physically not doing their
testing okay so but their testing is a
standard across the United States sorry
that's what I was asking that's
throughout the entire Northeast follow
up thank you um and just real quick you
mentioned 150 licenses are those
licenses for just bait um people who
Harvest bait those are 150,000 licensed
Anglers so those are the Anglers that
are using the bait that makes more
sense it's yeah you got 150,000 right
okay any further
questions seeing none thank you so much
for your testimony today thank you all
thank you
all
the the chair recognizes Amanda Hansen
from Upstream
policies chair Spain Vice chair olet and
members of the committee thank you so
much for letting me speak today um my
name is Amanda Hansen I'm from Upstream
policies we're a nonprofit organization
working to mitigate invasive species
issues across the the country I'm here
to um State my strong support for this
bill um we know that the use of uh live
bait fish is a major invasive species
and pathogen concern um the United
States States Geological Survey a
governmental institution the most
reliable source when it comes to
invasive species tracking um they state
that 10% of um aquatic invasive species
in the state um is attributed to the use
of live bait fish um they also state
that at least 10 aquatic species has
been introduced into New Hampshire
because of the use of live bait fish um
these numbers they align very well with
existing uh numbers in the literature um
there's several studies on this um one
study I can point out is from
2024 um it was a group they um they
looked at states that share suppliers
with New Hampshire and they found that
10% of the bait shops they contain um
Bait fish that have DNA from invasive
species one uh important thing to note
is also that this bill is not just to
protect from invasive species
introduction but it's also to protect
from new diseases entering New Hampshire
but also microscopic organisms this
could be mil foil but it could also be
um microscopic Seer muscle
um are spying water fle in the water
that the fish are transported in um just
a few notes uh on the current testing
that is occurring in all states in in
Arkansas um I guess it should be noted
that they are currently only testing for
five different diseases um this bill is
very much about taking a proactive
approach and about making sure that the
diseases we don't know about is not
going to enter New Hampshire um and
affect local ecosystems um also the
testing doesn't really
take into account invasive species um
there's this interesting thing happening
with Bait fish where they are often
founded in Arkansas and then transported
across the country and um it can
actually be very difficult to know the
flow of bait fish where the beat fish
are actually coming from it can be very
difficult to track um regarding the
testing I also just want to say there
are several studies out there despite
the testing showing that invasive
species and pathogens are present in the
bait fish supply
um one thing I can point that is the
natural resource department in Minnesota
in 2018 they published a report and
stating that they were going to ban the
import of live bait fish from Arkansas
particularly golden shiners which are
often used in New Hampshire um because
they could not be considered invasive
species free or pathogen
free right now we know that New
Hampshire is importing Bait fish from
Arkansas from Main Vermont and
Massachusetts um one of the problems
with this is that these are very small
fish um so even if you're an experienced
angler or maybe you're a bait shop owner
they can be very very difficult to
identify by eye um another problem is
that some Anglers unfortunately will
release uh the the remaining live bait
fish they are not using by the end of
the fishing trip directly into local
ecosystems um ex accelerating this
problem um we recently conducted a
survey of 250 or Anglers here in New
Hampshire and we found that 35% of
Anglers they release a live bait fish in
the end of their fishing trip this
number is very similar to what is found
in in in in studies across the the the
country um when these inter invations
occur they can't really be undone
invasive species management and pathogen
man management is extremely difficult um
it can not only devastate local
ecosystems it's also incredibly
expensive iive we know that on an
average ACC quaring invasive species in
the US they cost um on an average 7.4
million to manage it's very expensive
taking a proactive approach it's much
more cost effective um yeah we know that
all the states have already imple
implemented import bands to protect
their Fisheries this is true for
Minnesota Maine and Montana we know
there is a range of um of States taking
even stricter uh measures in in place
are implementing stricter policies
that's what um compared to what is
suggested here so that would be true for
Oregon Washington Idaho Utah Alaska most
Canadian provinces including Quebec um
one thing that's important to emphasize
about this bill is um Anglers would
still be able to use live bait fish it
just needs to be sourced from within the
state um the survey recently conducted
of 250 angl in New Hampshire found that
7 % of Anglers they support an import
ban on live bait fish because Anglers
don't want invasive species of pathogen
in their Waters either um this bill
could really address a root course of a
major invasive species pathway um it
could help protect New Hampshire's
natural resources for future Generations
um thank you so much for letting me
speak and I'm happy to take any
questions of
course thank you representative Harvey
uh thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question so these states um
that you've mentioned that either have a
band similar to this or even stricter
than us they must have the same supply
and demand problems that uh previous
testimony have has has indicated would
um happen if we uh pass this bill so do
you know how those states are managing
their supply and demand um
issues when because they
in spite of the fact that they passed
such a uh prohibition on importing fish
yeah um to my knowledge neither
Minnesota Maine or Montana has
experienced this Supply demand problem
um er yeah I think they haven't
experienced it we have interviewed a
range of natural resource departments
across the country um and this in
general hasn't come up as an issue um
yeah I guess one thing to mention is
that um alternative bait could could
also be used um I think artificial bait
a cut bait could be used also for ice
fishing and then I guess this is also an
and and you know we're talking about
protecting uh fisheries and recreational
fishing for future Generations um if New
Hampshire waters are going to be
infested with a invasive species or
pathogens this is going to be um it
could be a way bigger issue that's
that's very costly um both um
financially but also for for Lo
ecosystems any further
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony today thank
you chair calls Kyle
Baker uh good morning my name is Kyle
Baker I'm here on behalf of New
Hampshire Wildlife Federation New
Hampshire Wildlife Federation is a
93-year-old nonprofit profit that uh
nonpartisan nonprofit that advocates for
Hunting Fishing trapping and access to
lands to hunt fish and trap on um we're
here to oppose this piece of legislation
um I won't repeat every most everything
that I want to say has already been said
but we
have a lot of concern around what this
might happen particularly around ice
fishing in New Hampshire um we think the
process that's in place through fishing
game provides adequate protection to the
Fisheries here in New Hampshire um we
also see this as um some concerns around
picking and choosing Ching which
habitats we're seeking to add these
extra restrictions on Bill does not does
not um place any sort of restrictions on
what we would use in salt water or
Coastal Waters um in New Hampshire um
but just simply targets the the Inland
Waters and the Inland Fisheries so um we
have a number of concerns um but I don't
want to repeat everything that's already
been said so but happy to answer any
questions that someone might have thank
you any
questions seeing none thank
you and the chair calls the last
speaker Alan
[Music]
noot thank you um name is Alan new I've
been uh AJ's ba and tackle for 40 years
been in the business 45 years in the
retail business we've been
purchasing import bait over that many
years and haven't seen an issue with our
bait with the current laws that fishing
game has um they brought up the um
States the other states that are
involved in this that have gone to this
band well those states are much larger
than our state they have many more
Waters to trap our state is very minimal
like they said it's going to decimate
our Waters um for Bait fish you go to
Maine how many lakes and ponds do they
have versus US Minnesota or Idaho all
the other states they named are much
larger than we are um we rely on this
importation in order to survive uh with
the economy we have also this is a
global issue or a within the United
States issue what are we going to go to
next I mean you're going to ban all the
boats coming into the state um Maine has
a uh uh actually like the Massachusetts
has a tag that you have to clean your
boats coming into this state or into
their Waters into the Massachusetts
Reservoir there um we're going to go to
stuff like that um how far is this going
to go is is the question I have I mean
you know now you're picking on this but
there's more involved than just this
there's boats that keep coming from out
of state there's there's people that
keep coming from out of state you know
that are carrying bait who like they
said the illegal bait that gets you know
comes in from Massachusetts or I know
for a fact that some guys took some bait
from our state that was natively
trapped and took it to another state
that didn't allow it and that happened
this past Derby I know exactly you know
that stuff is happening that's going on
so that's just going to reverse and come
into our state some IL legal bait's
going to come into our state because of
the loss and you'll you'll see that
happen um everything else has been
pretty much said you know the economy
you know it will devastate our business
um not allowing that to happen
um and one last thing that I did is we
also did a online
petition which I
have uh 1,75 signatures if you want to
pass that up uh we'll are there multiple
copies or is that all one that's all I
okay we'll just give that to the clerk
here thank you and there was also 5,000
reviews on that as
well so you know people that were
interested in it um so on and so forth
with that
petition thank you are there any
questions seeing none uh thank you for
your testimony thank you is there anyone
who wanted to speak who's not had a
chance to speak yet if so you need to
fill out a card and pass it
Forward not seeing anyone I will close
the public hearing on hb720
FN committee we have a half an hour well
35 minutes before the next bill is to uh
is it wait a minute yeah 12:30
so uh I'm suggesting maybe we go ahead
and EXA this uh after a break we want to
take a break and uh we can probably take
a 15minute break and still be able to
exact bill before we have to start at
12:30 for another
bill if everybody comes back at like uh
10 after we'll uh we'll do some more
work 10 after
chairman
e
for
e e
okay with everybody back I will open the
exec session on hb720
and uh representative Murphy moves
itl and representative Durkin seconds
that we're open for
discussion representative
KH thank you Mr chairman Mr chairman
what I read from um nire fish and game
uh department and N Hamshire fish and
game and Marine resource committee
they're telling especially telling me or
they telling the committee that um this
is highly regulated industry there is
nothing wrong in there and if we go
ahead with this bill it's going to harm
the businesses and all the people that
uh fish in our state so therefore Mr Mr
chairman I think that I'm going to I'm
going to be voting no on this
bill no to the
itl no I mean I'm going to vote Yes on
the
[Laughter]
it anybody else discussion
representative
Harvey thank you Mr chair um you know
I'm what the one that asks the most
questions I think at at our hearings and
I still never get all of my answers but
we did have a 10 or 15 minute break and
I was able to talk with the Inland
Fisheries and um so forth and had more
of my questions answered it seems that
um the only states that um the fish are
imported from our Arkansas Vermont Maine
and one more
um thank you and
um the these have been um tested and
regulated and so forth Vermont's fish
would be the same as our fish um
so I am going to vote to support the itl
um that although I wonder if in the
future if there's some way that um we
might look at a a new industry that
supplies bait fishing rather it's
through fishing game or individual
Enterprises or whatever that's it
thanks thank
you I have a question for Inland
Fisheries then has anyone ever um tried
to apply to be a bait fish farm in New
Hampshire as other states have
done thank
you any further
discussion seeing none the clerk will
call the
role would you just because there was
some confusion would you just clarify
exactly what we're voting and so forth
yeah we're voting on itl
okay chairman
Spain yes Vice chairman olette yes
representative con yes representative
Smith yes representative tutor yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Aldrich representative Durkin yes clerk
is yes representative Harvey yes
representative Fox yes representative
lit yes representative Jacobs yes
representative oor yes representative
Pearson
yes it's 15
yeses
consent do we have to do something with
the am the amendment or were we no we
had to have a positive disposition in
order to even introduce the amendment so
it would have had to be a motion of OTP
before we could even amend add the
amendment you're correct thank you is
there are there any objections to
consent seeing none it'll go on consent
I will remind uh representative Murphy
that he owes a committee report on this
disposition and we still have
uh 13 minutes before we can start the
next bill uh it's good time to discuss
the fact that um I kind of didn't leave
us a lot of time for lunch in the
schedule uh my mistake I'm sorry about
that um just realized it as I was
looking things over uh I meant to leave
more
time so since we can't start a bill
early but we can start a bill late I'm
inclined to um whenever we finish this
next bill that starts at 12:30 give us
uh a 45 minute lunch and if we come back
a little after 1:15 we'll still be
starting that bill as soon as we come
back if there's no objections to that so
that everybody has enough time for lunch
no objections okay thank
you not yet we have one bill that starts
at 12:30 as soon as that one's over then
we'll go to lunch break for
45 I
know everybody is and I and I realized I
I wasn't leaving up a lot of time so I
wanted to make sure we all had
time I I was reminded during the chair
e
e e
all right I'm going to now open the
public hearing on HB 573
FN and the chair recognizes the prime
sponsor representative
love thank you Mr chair and rest of the
committee uh it's nice to be back here
spent my first two two uh terms on
fishing game here uh my name's uh
representative David love I represent
Rockingham 13 which is the town of
Derry there we
go um I'm here to introduce House Bill
573 and uh it's for uh fishing game
search and rescue funding uh I know uh
in the past uh fishing game has said
that they had sufficient funds but uh
you know this is a an Ever growing sport
uh you know uh it's it's probably the
most the fastest growing in the State uh
you know hiking and and a little bit of
mountain climbing and stuff and uh
people get in trouble uh also what uh
what hasn't been taken into account is
uh they they get a lot of federal money
from uh you know fishing game does and
uh that can be shut off at any time in
fact uh you know the the Trump
Administration has said we're going to
we're going to see some cutbacks and uh
you know that there is going to be some
pain but let's not let it happen here in
New Hampshire you know the uh the
revenue that comes from from hikers is
is I imagine as substantial as hunting
and fishing and uh you know we don't
want to lose the uh the the hotel and
meals and room tax revenue and uh that
kind of stuff but uh anyway uh it's it's
for
$200,000 and uh to go into the general
fund and uh as you can read anybody that
has it in front of them the the you know
fishing game is going to have to uh make
a do a report to uh the finance
committee and this committee uh um you
know on a quarterly basis on what
they're doing with the money so it isn't
going to be squandered and um you know
it's it' be a safety net is what it'll
be um I I think we need it if the
federal government ever shuts us off
from from using uh the the the Blackhawk
helicopters from uh from the National
Guard uh a lot of people might die you
know a few people might anyway and now
one's way too many uh this also uh
allows the the fishing game commissioner
to uh to uh do some uh point of sale uh
donations uh meaning they can go into uh
you know a sporting goods store somebody
will go into a sporting good store and
and buy a new pair of hiking boots or
whatever and um you know they just uh
ask them if they want to donate you know
a couple bucks or five bucks to to
fishing game search and rescue and uh
you know as the laws are now we they
have to have the permission to do it and
uh that's uh that's about
it well thank thank you any questions
representative
Harvey um so I understand you're you're
expecting to take $200,000 from the
general fund to go to search and rescue
correct M okay I guess followup followup
okay what if what if they don't use
$200,000 what happens to that money well
because they have to report uh how they
use it I imagine it'll just sit there or
go back to the general funds if they
don't use it if it's not needed um
you know they're certainly not going to
get another 200,000 next year if they
still have 198 left if they don't use
any but it's what it'll be is a safety
net um it's um I'd rather have a safety
net and not need it than need it and not
have it and
um you know like I said with the with
the federal cutback the looming Federal
cutbacks
um we just might see Recreation being uh
you know part of the cutbacks I I know
if I was and charge that' be a a lot of
where to
go any further questions representative
Khan thank you Mr chairman
representative thank you for taking my
question uh representative can you uh
explain to me that
um we're going to collect
$1 per person how you know and then if
we don't not collect
$200,000 what
happens uh are you talking about uh
paragraph one because the yeah the
changes are in two paragraph one is
already
there that's for uh registering boats
and no hivs and and things are you on
the see the changes of the do this is
the
change
not thank you I got it representative
ulette
uh I'm all set representative Khan
answer my ask my
question any further
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony today thank
you the chair recognizes representative
Weinstein from Rock
10 thank you Mr chair and thank you to
the committee for hearing my testimony
I'm represent representative Tony
Weinstein from New Market and I'm before
you today because I'm a
hiker I had hiked off and on with my
husband when we first met he planned
everything he would plan the hikes plan
our routs and he dealt with all of our
gear I went along but if I'm being
honest I never really enjoyed it then we
started visiting the White Mountains
with our sons and I started to more
frequently now part of the problem may
have been that my pace is best suited
for that of a four-year-old um but I
found my stride and I learned to not
just enjoy hiking but to really love
it I started hiking with friends we
hiked chakura and
Gunstock and some other mountains and
then decided to start tackling some of
the 4,000 Footers we hiked
Washington uh because you know go Bigg
or go home um and then we did the Fran I
Ridge and we hiked Mount Pierce and
others I never thought I could actually
um complete the list the thought of 18
Mile days seemed impossible um but I did
eventually finish summitting North Twin
on a beautiful summer
day I'm not telling you this to boast
but to explain that I'm a fairly
experienced
hiker I carry the T Essentials I
purchase my hike safe card
I check and double check and triple
check the weather
forecast but still accidents can happen
I was working on another list the 52
with a view and was hiking the mo
Mountain Traverse with a friend it's
about a 10m hike it was a picture
perfect day and we had hiked about 8
Miles um that afternoon when I
fell excuse me I heard the snap
I tried to get up I tried to scoot down
on my butt I said that I'd be damned to
have to call S um but as much as I
didn't want to we quickly realized that
we would need to call for
help um fishing game showed up assessed
the situation and started helping me
down the mountain to a waiting litter
where I was then transported by a group
of volunteers who took turns carrying me
down the
mountain I was prepared but I still
broke my ankle that that
day I can't imagine what would have
happened if I called and there is no one
there to
help so I'm here today to ask you to
support this bill and provide funding to
allow the men and women of fishing game
to be equipped to do their jobs thank
you thank you are there any
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony the chair calls Colonel Kevin
Jordan from New Hampshire fishing
game morning Mr chairman and members of
the committee for the record my name is
Kevin Jordan and I'm the colonel at New
Hampshire fishing game and I just want
to tell you if we don't have any money
we will be coming to get you if you ever
need it so and you could tell my Colonel
said
that um so we don't ever want to say no
to someone that's trying to help us and
I really appreciate representative
lovees concerned for this he's done it
uh I think this is the second or third
time he's tried to do this um he does
make a valid point about the about we do
use the helicopter in life and death um
and we've been very fortunate uh that
the the United States government has
allowed us to do that because there's
laws that say you can't use a federal
asset for a state uh without payment and
so they've written it off as training in
most cases and I I have testified to
this a couple of times but because of
their their work with us uh I'm being
told they're some of the best pilots in
the in the country so that when they go
to Afghanistan they're very good at
flying in the mountains because they do
it here in the White Mountains so we all
benefit from that but if we were ever
having if we ever had to pay for that
helicopter that resource would be gone
because we can't pay for it one mission
is is I get bills from them when they do
a mission so I know what it cost uh and
then they submit a waiver to get the
bill um forgiven and I've seen bills 80
$90,000 for a single flight to get
people but I'm here to tell you if we
don't have it people will die the only
time I use it is when people are near
death uh and they literally have plucked
people from Death uh at 82 degrees core
temperature and got them to a hospital
and if we carried them down and bounced
them down the trail we would certainly
kill them doing that so so it is a
valuable resource it's one I'm concerned
about if we lose um so I told represent
of love I would support it right now I'm
I'm really happy and excited to say that
we're making ends meet with what we have
so just so you know representative Khan
we for since the 80s Senator blazel put
in a l in the 80s that allowed us to
take a dollar from every uh OHV every
ATV every um boat hunting license or a
fishing license and put it into a search
and rescue account and that is at that's
never changed from the 80s uh even
though inflation really has changed um
so that gives us
$180,000 roughly each year for search
and rescue I'm spending three to 400,000
depending on the year we do a couple
hundred missions a year uh the cost
varies but it averages out to about 180
missions each year and we're spending
this past year I spent
$400,000 uh for that so the hike safe
card picks up a lot of that slack last
year it brought us in
$363,000 in Revenue so it's it's been
really a good program um and it's helped
us a lot so right now we're good I mean
I can always use more because we're in a
position where where more is always
better but we're in a better place today
than we were 10 years ago when I started
coming over here so um but I don't I
don't want to ever say no to help so
that's basically where I'm at with
that thank you questions representative
Harvey
so I I'm conf fused so we would
appropriate $200,000 from general fund
to search and rescue uh okay but you
might not need it because you're making
ends meet right so where does that money
so search the search and rescue account
is a non-aps account so money that's in
there that we don't use uh would carry
over for the next uh budget year so it
it doesn't go away it would be and we
file reports now with Finance we're
required annually to file a report every
year with with what we spend um and how
much is in with the balance in the
account so that would be monitored uh
and my expectation would be if we don't
use it we wouldn't get
it followup please followup so okay so I
think you would use the 200,000 but I'm
just play I can assure you I would right
so I'm just but I don't want to say I I
think it's important where you're taking
a vote I don't want you to think that I
that we have to use it if we had it I
would use it to buy equipment I would
use it to buy Cruisers and other
equipment we haven't bought for search
and rescue for a long time so my
question is kind of like a devil's
advocate question okay so if you don't
use this 200,000 it stays in this
uh with the state has worked that way so
um so I wouldn't expect that and we
wouldn't you know we wouldn't you
wouldn't just spend it on anything I
mean there's a lot of things that we
used to buy in search and rescue we used
to buy cruisers for the for the advance
search and rescue team that uses the
Cruisers more for search and rescue than
anything else we haven't been able to do
that for years um so that money I would
use for those types of things it
wouldn't be a waste but it but we're not
desperate for it I guess is what I'd ask
you to think of
about representative
ulette uh thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question yes sir just
to to clarify make sure I understood
what you're saying so uh in this past
year you spent about 360,000 yes in
rescues the uh hike safe card brought in
about 350,000 yes sir and with the other
dollar from the registration from the
snowmobiles the atbs fishermen so you
had about 160,000 140,000 uh
uh excess funds the year that went into
your your account correct that we used
yes yes okay thank you yes
sir representative tutor thank you Mr
chair thanks for taking my question yes
sir um I'm just wondering uh this
obviously you know it's going to be a
really tough budget year and yes and
selling Finance on $200,000 might be a
tough sell yes I'm wondering if we were
to think about maybe changing the the
fee from a dollar to $2 maybe you know
in next in the next session if that
might be a better approach to get you
the same kind of money long overdue
frankly um I don't know those
communities might come out you know
those those folks that ride ATVs and buy
hunting license and boating uh might
come out against it because they feel
like they're paying the Lion Share now
and I can and the statistics show that
we're not they're not receiving the The
Lion Share the services the hikers are
but those are those are also Solutions
uh to that and and you know anything
that you decide to do I would agree it's
going to be a tight budget year um and
it and I think it would be a hard
sell representative Harvey so to piggy
back on his question um um that it is a
tight budget year and and and if we keep
acre this 200,000 that's a lot of money
um why don't you raise the he hike safe
card as well um who who has the
authority to do that we do and so I'm
I'm careful with hik safe and I'll tell
you why each year it has since 2015 it's
gotten better it's improved every year
and so my feeling was and this is
strictly my opinion is when we hit a
plateau when we get to a point where
we're not gaining anything or in fact
starting to lose then I would then I
would choose to go in and try to change
something I'm a little leery of because
remember it's voluntary so I'm a little
of scaring people away uh and it if it's
working well I'm a firm believer and let
it work well and stay out of it so I
haven't done that as yet it's been
suggested a lot and and it's certainly
something I would we're going to
consider but each year it seems to climb
and I and when it's climbing and I look
at that figure I think well we're doing
pretty well I don't know that I want to
rock that boat just yet um it's been a
long time coming and and it's valuable
to us and and I you know it doesn't seem
to hurt the hikers
who are paying for them that are buying
these cards they seem good doing it so I
haven't raised it but we can we do have
the authority to raise that
Fe any further questions representative
Khan thank you Mr chairman and thank you
cor Jordan for taking my question coron
Jordan in my time in this committee many
many times you told us that how much
rescue you did some of them are good U
you know good stories some of them are
sad stories
uh can you tell us that how much uh you
money you get back from those families
and organizations that they you do
rescue and you have just say $50,000
cost but do you get any reimburse from
those uh people so we do we get two ways
that we get it so people are uh Believe
It or Not people make donations uh which
is very nice they'll uh people that
we've rescued have been uh we've reached
out to them on occasion uh for the
outdoor Council the volunteer groups
that help us that don't receive any
funding we've reached out and asked for
donations to go to them and people are
good about that so about every month I'm
bringing small donations before my
commission to get approval to use that
goes into the search and rescue account
and then we build for some rescues we do
have the ability the legislature gave us
the ability uh a number of years ago to
Bill irresponsible hikers we don't do
that a lot um it has to be pretty
outrageous behavior before I'll do it so
out of 180 missions we build 10 to 12 of
those folks every year uh and we enjoy
about a 61 or 62% collection rate so we
collect probably a little over half of
what we bill um the problem comes in
that some of those missions run 50 and
$60,000 so that's a that's a hard pill
for people to pay back uh we negotiate
payment schedules we we negotiate the
amount some times I settle for a much
lesser amount for people that have no
ability to pay so we we do generate some
of that and the donations seem to
continue to come we got I we received a
donation last night for $5,000 to go
into the search and rescue account so a
lot of people are doing that which is
helpful that account is in better shape
today than it's been in the 34 years
I've been here so I'm very happy to say
and I'm only looking for that to improve
I didn't want to say no to help that's
that's my reason for being here I'll
never say no if someone wants to help
but we're we're doing better than we
have in a long
time any other
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony
today the chair calls Meredith Hatfield
from The Nature Conservancy
good afternoon Mr chairman uh members of
the committee I am Meredith Hatfield
from The Nature Conservancy I do have a
testimony letter making its way around
and today I have the honor of
representing not only the nature
conservancy but also the society for the
protection of New Hampshire forests and
the Appalachian Mountain Club um we are
all uh strong partners with fishing game
and we really see the agency's work as
so critical to us fulfilling our
missions um that anytime we get a chance
to support the agency uh in seeking
funding particularly as has been noted
in a very challenging budget year uh we
take the opportunity to do so I think
you've asked some really good questions
um that may warrant uh making some
changes to this legislation um I did
want to point out that um all three
organizations have uh participated in
several study committees over the years
over more than a decade there have been
a few study committees looking at how to
uh ensure that the agency has
sustainable funding um and thank you to
the chairman for his service on the last
one which was um last summer and fall
and during that conversation a lot of um
I would say new stakeholders
participated and expressed their
interest and support for being a part of
uh long-term Funding Solutions and the
part of this bill on line 24 that allows
the uh fishing game director to invest
in technology to enable collection of
donations which um the prime sponsor
referenced at point of sale we think
could be a really important tool that as
people are buying equipment if they were
offered the option to you know donate a
few dollars on top of their purchase uh
we think that could be a really valuable
tool to increase um the resources that
fishing game has to perform important
duties like search and rescue uh and
with that I'd be happy to answer any
questions thank you any
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony the chair calls Robert Johnson
II from New Hampshire Farm
Bureau take the big
chair yeah they changed all of them
I thank you Mr chair members of the
committee for the record Rob Johnson
representing the New Hampshire Farm bu
is a federation's policy director Farm
Bureau is a Federation of New
Hampshire's 10 County Farm Bureau
organizations consisting of of just
under 2500 member Farm families
supporters and Affiliated businesses and
similar to others uh we wanted to show
our support for for the agency uh
upwards of uh our Members Own and manage
upwards of a few hundred thousand acres
of of of land in the state most of it
being open for recreational uh Pursuits
hunting and fishing and such and our
members take pride in keeping their land
open for others to
use and we also consider ourselves a
consider fishing game a partner as well
a valued partner and at our last annual
meeting in November our County Farm
Bureau delegates which we had 29 of them
from the various counties uh adopted a
resolution uh supporting uh State
funding for search and rescue uh efforts
and we we we did this
um because we we want the we need i' say
we don't want but we need the agency to
have the personnel and resources uh to
assist our members uh with with such
thing as upholding the fishing game laws
on their property to be available when
there are landowner uh related issues as
as well as uh we addressing uh crop
damage which uh you know happens on our
farm and goes along with uh healthy
Wildlife populations in the state and
now I'll leave it at that thank you for
your
attention thank you any
questions seeing none thank you for your
time today is there is there anybody out
there that wanted to speak on this bill
that has not had a chance to
speak seeing none I will now close the
hearing on HB 573
FNA we have
have another bill coming up at
115 um but we have not yet had our
lunch so I am going
to break for
lunch and give everybody 45 minutes so
we'll be late coming into the next bill
but that's just because of all the
overrun we've had so uh since we can
start a bill after it's been published
to T start but not before we're going to
be in that situation and uh if everybody
can come back for 145 we'll we'll open
up that bill at 145 instead
of5
okay everybody go have
lunch
e
e e
it being 1:45 the time and date certain
when we delayed the meeting too um I am
going to open the hearing public hearing
on 589 FN and I recognize the prime
sponsor of the bill uh representative
Schultz thank you Mr chair and thank you
to the committee it's an honor to be
here I think it's my first time coming
to fishing game uh you know I I don't
even think I've subbed on your committee
before so it's really an honor to be
here I did pass passed out an amendment
uh that I believe tremendously improves
the bill but I'll get to that in a
minute I wanted to take a step back
first and say hi I represent uh about a
third of conquered including where we
are sitting now so you're in my district
um and I also want to make it clear that
for this whole topic I would not have
taken this bill on if it didn't support
people who fish and people who hunt I
grew up in Kentucky where half of my
family did fish regularly and I was in
that part of the family more often and
the other half uh did hunt and somehow
my dad did both and so I grew up eating
what I called as a little girl the
Bambi deer squirrel rabbits that was a
part of my upbringing so and how to look
for buckshot so you didn't uh bite into
it that kind of a thing so I would not
have taken part in this bill if in any
way it I would
um cause a problem for hunters and
Anglers who are uh into the conservation
you know and doing these things the
correct way it is a bipartisan bill with
Republicans and Democrats somehow more
state senators as co-sponsors than reps
but anyway let me H to to the key points
first of all
um what is want want and waste so um one
waste is a disgraceful Act of leaving a
wounded or killed animal in the field or
Forest without making a reasonable
effort to retrieve it for consumption or
use it is a senseless waste of life and
a blatant disregard for the principles
of responsible Wildlife
stewardship and so what are Wildlife
killing contests these contests are
organized competitions in which
participants compete for cash prizes and
other incentives to kill his many of a
targeted species as possible they turn
our state's public Trust of wildlife
into mere targets for entertainment
rather than respecting them as part of
our shared natural heritage and I will
step back to say the conversations that
I have after filing the initial bill did
lead to the amended version that does
recognize that for example uh we started
the list all these exceptions that we
wanted like you know you had a um
fishing contest of who had the biggest
bass and you know a fishing derby that
would be an exception and other things
like who caught the biggest uh or most
uh turkeys in this season the way you do
that over a season and what you're
allowed to do or you know anyway people
were coming up with so many exceptions
we took a step back and decided to amend
the bill uh approaching it in a much
different way because we could keep
coming up with exceptions that seemed
reasonable uh till the cows come home
and I wasn't sure that that was the best
place for us as uh legislature to get to
drill that down so deeply so the Crux of
the amended version is essentially to uh
allow uh for the rul making process to
do that piece of it so the bill itself
as a me if you decide to amend it um is
in fact addressing these points that I'm
going over now
but then at the discretion of um the way
the bill outlines it uh then leaves it
to the rul making process with the
director um fish and game um and we'll
get to that um so like I said it's not a
restrict restricting any lawful hunting
or fishing as licensed and regulated by
the New Hampshire fishing game uh folks
ethical Hunters follow Fair Chase
principles and respect the animals they
pursue this legislation simply seeks to
end the Reckless wasteful Slaughter that
gives real Hunters a bad name and is
increasingly condemned by Wildlife
professionals
Nationwide if the sheer immorality of
leaving dead animals to rot or killing
for sport prizes isn't enough to ban
these contests consider these two major
points the association of Fish and
Wildlife agencies of which New Hampshire
fishing game is a member opposes these
unethical
practices and the North American model
of wildlife conservation which New
Hampshire fishing game explicitly
endorses upholds these relevant core
principles Wildlife Resources are
conserved and held in trust for all
citizens and Wildlife may only be killed
for a legitimate non-frivolous
purpose and I'll also say a constituent
brought this to my attention this topic
and I've been working with Chris shadler
and Welden Bosworth um of the New
Hampshire Wildlife Commission and we
have been collaborating with a number of
folks and I actually would like to defer
to them on the specc specifics of that
and the amendment to to some degree um
and so anyway so this bill would really
be a necessary step to the process of
upholding ethical hunting traditions and
and angling traditions and ensure our
state continues to lead in responsible
conservation
um so that's my brief hopefully brief
presentation
um yeah there we
go thank you for your testimony are
there any
questions oh Mr chair I forgot about one
thing I should take questions first
though if you work it into a question
great if not you can follow up with it
uh representative
Harvey so
uh um
so I I'm just so the the bill is is one
thing but are the amendment is to put
both of these things into the rule
making for fishing gaming okay so if we
vote for the amendment
then what what is in the bill is
basically n and void right it that'ss
the whole bill except for the enacting
Clause okay which is the introductory
piece okay got it thank you and it um
really does give uh
the executive director the authority to
work um on these adoption of rules and
that's where they can sus out Does it
include this fishing derby or anything
that has brought to their attention um
you know the way those things are raised
in any fashion so rulemaking process
then takes the front stage in this bill
and I will say there was another
suggestion that I am open to including
and rephrasing a little bit of the
wording around what want and waste is to
say uh wild animal or wild bird as a
part of that um I'm I'm not sure why
they aren't suggesting fish but maybe
that is a different topic than this
amendment must address but we can figure
that out for sure but so and just know
that I'm open to that
Amendment thank you any further
questions representative
Durkin thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um so these
hunting comp contests can you tell me
and be a little specific how many there
are in the state and of what species
they're hunting or I I'm not sure of
that myself I think are the folks that
have collaborated with me will know
better um I mean in some cases we may
not know what those are but um I will
defer to them on that answer they're um
much more knowledgeable about when these
things have taken place in the past
thank
you any further
questions seeing none thank you for your
time today thank you I really appreciate
it oh and Mr chair I did place the
suggested um and has read ink on it I
did not have enough copies for the whole
Committee of the suggested additional
Amendment did you give a copy to the
clerk uh think I did leave one on your
spot too it has red ink in it and it's
uh enumerates it says wild animal I can
give you my copy I'll pass it oh great
okay perfect she she has one thank you
oh excellent thank you so
much thank you for your
time the chair now calls uh Susan
Garcia hi thank you for taking my
testimony this is my first time
testifying welcome I'm nervous I'm
emotional don't be we all people well
I'm emotional because of what's at stake
uh to me uh I'm from Peterboro
gratuitous violence and killing is not
the sign of a healthy
Society I value life I value
nature I value
creation I value the very strong family
systems
that nature has in
place the balance of
nature um the issues of the balance of
Nature has led to negative
repercussions when you remove the top
predators this has been evidenced by the
deer explosion and what do we do with
all the deer and all the killing of deer
that has to happen because they don't
have a top
predator uh people are afraid of coyotes
I don't think they're as bad as people
think uh people like to shoot coyotes I
understand there is no limitation on
shooting coyotes coyotes have a very
strong family system they do well if
left to their own hierarchy to keep
their numbers
down when you go and you kill a
mother you're encouraging the other
females in the pack to
reproduce so the idea that you could
just kill off the coyotes and that's
going to solve the problem of people
being afraid of coyotes is you're
actually Fanning the flames on
reproduction so we do need to have those
top
predators uh wolves are protective
species I would love to see wolves come
back into our balance of nature in New
Hampshire uh they cannot be easily
identified as being separate from
coyotes I I would not be able to tell a
wolf from a
coyote um there's a difference in the
eye placement a difference in the ears
and maybe the size but really uh
apparently people have shot wolves or or
wolves that are
hybrids uh because they thought they
were
coyotes so
um I think I've pretty much expressed
what I was thinking I just want to add
one more thing we have such a wonderful
State wonderful nature wonderful
woods and and we're or nature is already
suffering from 50% declines of say the
gray fox the red fox the Martins the I'm
not remembering the name of those scary
ones the fisher cats the cats
Fishers but th this is all you know
having killing contests just gives an
Open Season to further decimate the
wildlife we have and cherish so thank
you very
much thank
you the chair now recognizes Welden
Bosworth thank you Mr chair uh the uh
Welden Bosworth from Guilford I did turn
in some uh written testimony a couple of
days ago and I will assume that you have
already accessed it or you will I am
just going to emphasize a couple of
things and and talk about why we wanted
this
bill unfortunately in New Hampshire
there's many of our species are used as
essentially disposable
targets they're killed because some
think some people think that the only
good Predator is a dead one so you have
people that uh hunt a variety of our
Predators we have nine Predators now or
what we call Miso Predators which has
next step down like raccoons and so
forth and these are kind of uh the way
the seasons run in uh New Hampshire
these are available to shoot the seasons
are open on these species from five to 7
months a year and you don't need to get
a tag or a
permit to shoot them and there's no duty
to report if you kill
them so we don't really know how many
are shot but this is something where we
have people that actually hunt these as
Predators shoot them and because there's
no Duty or no system for understanding
how many are shot they're basically
disposed of and there in lies the
rationale for the W and waste other
things happened that fall into that as
well the second thing is the gentleman
over here asked about Wildlife killing
contest
there have been Wildlife killing
contests in New Hampshire back three or
four years ago there are three three or
four different sporting goods shops that
uh ran them I am unaware of any
currently uh I think there was a lot of
back in 2020 we actually introduced this
Wildlife killing contest ban bill and I
think some of that may have gone
underground I don't know that but I
think the important thing is with a ban
on that we can be sure or reasonably
sure that we won't have them anymore and
that's the the basis and the rationale
for submitting this bill uh thank you
the rest of it in my testimony I
submitted if there are any questions I'd
be glad to entertain
them thank you are there any questions
representative Durkin thank you for
taking my question thank you Mr speaker
thank you for taking my question as more
of a statement uh you made a statement
that you think that these contests have
gone
underground you should be really careful
about saying something like that because
that very misleading representative
Durkin please make them actual questions
okay I was just making a statement I'm
sorry um so you don't know of
any contests that going on presently I
know of no killing con contest that's
been generally advertised okay how about
put it that way thank
you any other
questions representative tutor so when
you go to the want and waste part of the
bill
um someone should a fox or
raccoon or Fisher I'm not sure what the
season is on Fisher but there is seasons
on the others yeah um you take expecting
me to take it home and bake
it uh you have you should have a purpose
for doing it other than just to kill it
in my estimation so basically the idea
this ISS unless you use that so there's
fur there's meat uh that's the use of a
species so you need to have a rationale
for taking its life
does the uh followup Mr chair follow up
um I guess this is the point of your
bill but um the fishing game sets a bag
limit for a certain number of animals
that that I can shoot during a
season um if I'm at the fur then yes I
would keep the fur but I might read the
cockus in the woods after I skinned it
would you consider that to be want and
waste it depends on what kind of carcass
for instance if you shoot a deer usually
you gut them in the woods and you take
the whole the rest of the deer out the
guts are left there
right again clarifying followup Mr chair
follow up again I'm back to the raccoon
the fox the animals that you're probably
not going to
take then why would you shoot
it well the use of the fur certainly
wouldn't be included in the SWAT and
waste all right never mind Mr I'm good
representative Harvey um so I have here
the the North American model of wildlife
conservation um and I was briefly
looking at it quickly last night
isn't uh one of the tenants of that um
conservation to not um encourage want
and
waste it depends on how you you can
interpret some of that uh as one as not
you as as referring to waste yes as uh
representative Schultz said the the
tenants that we basically hung our hat
on there was that Wildlife should not be
taken for frivolous
reasons thank you yes I'm reading that
right now so okay thank
you representative
Smith thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question this may be a
question better suited for Colonel
Jordan um I think this is maybe where uh
reptor was going if I shoot a fox that's
coming into my chicken CP I'm not going
to eat the fox nor do I want the fur
would this bill if it became
law have a negative impact upon the
person that did that definitely not the
fox coming in your
chicken uh your chickens is a nuisance
animal well within the regulations to
either personally take care of it or
basically get
an agent to do that for
you any further questions representative
Harvey so
um isn't that also in statute that if an
animal is um causing harm to your
property in any way you are allowed to
take that animal yes it is yeah a be
eight my rabbit and fishing game said I
could kill
it tough further
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you for the
time the chair calls K
kushman she had to
leave oh Mr chair that that's my fault
um she stopped me in the hallway uh
because of the delay she had to leave
and she asked me to tell you and I
forgot I'm
sorry chair calls o
web good afternoon thank you members of
the House fishing game and Marine
Resources committee dear chairman
members of the commission I did submit a
PDF but for some reason it didn't go
through so I'm just going to review what
I had in my submission which you have a
copy thank you today we seem to be on
the presence of change chaos and the
Very possibility to one day lose the
opportunity to voice our public opinions
I am thankful to have this opportunity
to do to do so today for the record I am
asking you to ban The Killing contest
and want and waste and approve of HB 589
I can't even begin to comprehend why I
or we even need to do this what is it
about killing contests that's even
remotely acceptable to anyone it should
not be I'd ask each of you to have if
you've given any thought to what a
killing contest is and the repercussions
of such when when I think of contests I
think of fundraiser contests at schools
sports dance or art contests killing
contests are just another example of an
allowable witnessed in humanity to
another living being killing contests
have been documented in our bloody
barbaric cruel and I would also add a
perverse excuse to destroy and even at
times torture for some unfounded excuses
do you believe in dog fighting do you
believe in
fighting do you believe allowing people
to chase down coyote any time of the day
or night year round be it a pregnant or
nursing mother or a pup and then shoot
them through the stomach so they can
suffer and bleed to death is ethical it
is a well documented that coyote are
chased by hounds for miles to their
death exhaustion or chased down by
snowmobiles injured and maimed disabled
until they are killed yes sadly even
this is considered acceptable and not
illegal in New Hampshire
imagine for just one moment the stress
horror suffering and pain these animals
must endure for the sake of some
gruesome bloody contest this is not a
form of ethical Fair Chase hunting or
even a resource for food there they
become want in waste of animal bodies
maimed tortured and killed left to rot
in their pool of blood it is the epitome
of inhumanity these contests are not
always publicly visible as with social
media and the internet there is a dark
circle of shared information that
perpetuates this very real vilification
of coyotes here in New Hampshire and
across the country do you know that even
young impressionable children attend
these contests what part of a civil
society AG agrees to allows this
bloodthirsty barbaric and most vile form
of animal abuse toward a wild animal my
dear parents never lost their sense of
right and wrong morals ethics and how to
be a good neighbor and respect for all
things they taught me and my siblings by
word and by example and I'm truly
grateful to them I have spent my adult
career in the healthc care profession
treating and caring for people I can
honestly say that there is no question
in my mind or in the many people I have
spoken with and work with that no one
agrees that killing contests are
acceptable but rather are a cruel and
barbaric bloody ugly stain on New
Hampshire and any organization that
supports it I urge you to dig deep into
yourselves and consider joining other
ethical minded Hunters conservationists
the Humane Society and other states that
have already banned killing contests
that would be Arizona California our
neighbors Vermont Massachusetts Colorado
New Mexico Maryland New York Washington
and Oregon it is not only the ethical
decision it is the right and best
decision for New Hampshire its residents
visitors and tourism an ethically
conscientious state that has regard for
the Humane treatment of animals both
wild and domestic is not a bad thing it
is actually a very positive and welcome
stance I urge you to please make the
most appropriate decision band killing
contest and wanting Ways by voting
support of this Bill thank
you thank you ma'am I almost stopped you
to correct you but I decided to let you
continue and then correct you afterwards
I was here serving on this committee and
was a co-sponsor of our Wild Life
cruelty bill that we passed and I can
assure you that Colonel Jordan would
certainly charge anyone who tried to
chase down coyotes with a snowmobile and
run them over or maim them it is against
the law and so I would be careful in
your assertions thank you very glad to
hear that thank
you the chair now recognizes
Mark
noo I did my best
chairman uh members of the committee
thank you for the opportunity to speak
uh my name is Mark noino I live in
penbroke I'm here to voice my support
for House Bill 589 FN which would ban
Wildlife killing contest in the state of
New
Hampshire my support for this bill is
based on three principles I believe in
science-based management of Nature and
Wildlife I support Second principle I
support and respect hunters and hunting
and the valuable role that they play in
keeping our ecosystem in
Balance the third principle I believe
that the natural world of my state of
New Hampshire belongs to all of us as
well as to our children and to our
grandchildren I have not not seen any
evidence to suggest that Wildlife
killing contests can be reconciled with
any of these three principles that I've
mentioned regarding my first principle
science-based Wildlife Management I've
spent many hours reading studies and
doing research and I've not been able to
find a single study that shows that
Wildlife killing contests help the
Predator prey balance nor improve
livestock protection but I was able to
read study after study including ones
conducted by UNH scientists that
indicated that indiscriminate lethal
control of predators can be
counterproductive often leading to
increased Predator populations due to
Adaptive reproductive
strategies the same studies also
demonstrated that non-lethal methods of
management had just as much or perhaps
more benefit than lethal ones this also
helped to explain to me why 10 states
all with active and cherished hunting
itions uh have already banned Wildlife
killing contests the boards of these
States including Vermont Arizona New
York and others reviewed the science and
came to the same
conclusion regarding my second principle
hunters and the valuable role they play
in balancing Wildlife populations I
could find no evidence that Wildlife
killing contests specifically provide
any benefit to that cause nor to the
exercise or enjoyment of hunting in
general I did find that at at least some
Hunters worry that Wildlife killing
contests create a negative image of
hunting and potentially harm public
opinion supporting this concern I found
that 84% of Americans agree with hunting
for meat according to the council to
advance hunting and the Shooting Sports
while only 14% support killing contests
according to a 2022 Remington research
group poll so it's clear that there's
wide support for hunting but only
limited support for
contests regarding my third principle
that the natural world belongs to all of
us this is the one that motivated me
most to speak here
today as I was researching the subject a
specific article and interview jumped
out at me and in the article there was a
gentleman who was president uh of an
organization called The Mohawk Valley
and Cat Club just came up in the
article uh and he said that Wildlife con
contest this is in New York the wildlife
contest helps sustain his organization's
membership uh he also said that even
though New York banned the contest that
he would continue holding them under
under another name and the exact quote
that stood out to me in this public
article said some of our guys have
$6,000 scopes on their rifles and
they're never going to get to use them
for anything else this club has been in
my family since the 40s and I don't want
to lose it so my question is is as a
citizen of any state whether it's New
York or New Hampshire why does a small
group of people in a private club get to
dictate interests that are for their
monetary benefit when the majority of
the opinion is against this Behavior the
wildlife and public land in my state
belongs to everyone and it should be
carefully managed according to
Scientific principles that benefit us
all and not the special interests of of
a few in a private club thank you Mr
chairman and
committee thank you for your testimony
are there any
questions seeing none thank you for your
time
today the chair calls Joan
O'Brien thank you chair
members of the committee my name is Joan
O'Brien and I'm from amher New Hampshire
and I am here uh in support of HB 589
not just for myself but for everybody in
my life who reacts with shock and
disbelief when I tell them there's such
a thing as a wock killing
contest I believe that killing contests
where an entire species is vilified and
set aside for extermination embodies the
worst of human nature
and two aspects that are extremely
disturbing have already been mentioned
but I'll mention them again is the
presence of children at these
events children at these events are
going to become desensitized to violence
and to
suffering and they're going to see the
adults in their lives modeling that it's
okay to treat certain animals like
garbage and the second thing that really
concerns me is the use of the
high-powered weaponry
I also had the quote we just heard about
the gun club owner saying my guys have
these $66,000 Scopes where else are they
going to be able to use
them and in my photos you're going to
see a picture of a couple of guys
dressed like they're about to go into
Iraq and they to kill two innocent
foxes defenseless
animals Wildlife killing contests have
no place in the civilized society and I
urge the committee to support this Bill
and end these senseless massacres thank
you thank you are there any questions
representative ulet please uh thank you
Mr chairman and thank you for taking my
question I see the picture of the two
gentlemen on the back with the two foxes
have they done anything
illegal apparently not thank I mean I
don't know what state that is it's but
it's ex it it illustrates what these
things look like even if this isn't New
Hampshire it could well be New
Hampshire follow up but you don't know
of any
um of the I do not know of any killing
contests
personally representative
Khan thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my questions uh because we
are talking
about making a law in New Hampshire can
you tell us that all these picture I'm
seeing these pictures are from New
Hampshire no I I cannot tell you that
they're from New Hampshire again they
could well be it's the same kind of
contests they're happening in all but
like five states Across the
Nation any other
questions seeing none thank you for your
time
today the chair calls Emily Murphy
hello um thank you for letting me speak
um
uh um and thank you for considering this
SP um all of you um committee members um
this is a no-brainer for me um of course
we should ban um Wildlife killing
contests um and I I want to say that I I
brought my third grade daughter here
today um she loves animals um especially
wolves and bobcats
I told her about the band because I just
learned about it um like a couple days
ago and she was so upset to learn that
they were allowed in New Hampshire in
the first place I actually let her miss
school today so she could be here and
see how our government works um
particularly with something that she
cares so much about I asked her if she
wanted to speak but understandably she
declined
so I also wanted to tell you of
something that happened when I was about
seven or eight years old old um a friend
told me of a place called cat hell um
and they said where any cat that goes
there they get shot on
site I don't know if it was true I was
seven or eight but I believe them and
the idea of it horrified me and it stuck
with me I'm 51 now I still remember
learning about
catell and the idea um the shooting on
sight and the complete disregard for the
life of the animal was what was so
horrifying I mean I knew that cats were
euthanized at shelters and pounds like
it's it's not like I was like ah no desk
never um but I think it was that
shooting on site for fun just um almost
like a contest
there um and to kill in the name of
wildlife control is
wrong New Hampshire is better at
wildlife control that meaning killing
contests um we have very highly trained
people who do that for a living
um and just because something is wild
and not domesticated sorry does not mean
it should be legally bound to such
treatment that is not appropriate
wildlife control so please each of you
on this committee I implore you not to
yield to a minority who must want to
keep these killing contests I guess in
the name of Heritage or tradition
although as somebody mentioned I mean
some people Proclaim dog fighting as
their Heritage and tradition and I want
you to please think of what this
decision says to our children and future
Generations your ability to pass
legislation is such an important tool I
don't need to tell you that you all know
that past legislators excuse me past
legislators and citizens um we can thank
for why we have laws prohibiting adults
from beating their children for
example and that was not always the case
in our history as I'm sure many of you
know if uh those of you are students of
History um some of the ear protections
for children in our country arose by
arguing the fact that laws existed that
would have protected an animal from
enduring the same treatment that this
child was undergoing now I must say how
sad that children needed to be at least
considered on the level of animals to
get that basic protection um but how
important having those laws on the books
was we need to have basic protections
from some of the worst types of
treatment that are possible even for
animals anal even for
Animals Wildlife killing contest
squarely goes into that category of some
of the worst types of treatment that are
possible um thank you for your time and
your service in the New Hampshire
legislature and I'm Emily Murphy I'm
from Dober New Hampshire I don't know if
I said that thank you oh and I have to
wait for dut sorry only you want to are
you willing to take any questions sure
are there any
questions seeing none all right thank
you thank you very much for your
testimony
the chair calls
Louie chattle
Jr I did my best it
worked good afternoon chairman and
distinguished members of the fishing
game committee my name is lucel JR I
live in new ipswitch with my wife and
two wonderful huskys I have spent the
majority of my life keeping people safe
but I realized it was time for me to
make a change I was an EMT for 15 years
I went on to be a police officer in New
Hampshire for 15 years and I retired
after that I then went to work in a
hospital in New Hampshire in Chief of
chief of security keeping people safe
and since then I've been in a in a
safety coordinated role in Manch
Manchester for the last two and a half
years during all this time the care and
respect of animals has always been my my
passion and since animals do not have a
voice I'm going to use mine today to
advocate for them I'm also going to be
repeating some of the things but that
have been said and I think it's worth to
hear them and they were all very good
points I promise to be brief but when
I'm done here today I hope I leave you
with one thing my passion for Animals
before I ask for your support I'd like
to outline the wildlife killing contest
and I realized some of this has been
said but but it's easier for me just to
say it
uh these contests are nothing more than
recreational and organized Slaughter
they may take place over a specific
period of time such as 24 48 hours
during this time the goal is to kill as
many animals as possible and the one
that has the most combined weight of
dead animals wins the prize if larger
animals are not available any animal
will do the more animals that are killed
the better one has the chance to win a
contest sadly our most impressionable
children often witness or participated
in these cont contest with all the
violence our children are regularly
exposed to these contests send a message
that it's fun or thrilling to kill as
many animals as you can this should not
be the Legacy we want to leave our
future
generations to put things in perspective
I outlined eight brief talking points
first one being respect Wildlife killing
contests do not respect Wildlife all
they do is promote a culture of hate and
disrespect towards animals ecological
balance Wildlife plays a crucial role in
maintaining our ecosystem these killing
contests disrupt its balance and can
greatly affect all nearby Wildlife
populations Banning uh Wildlife killing
contest does not mean Banning hunting I
understand and support e ethical hunting
practices but killing contests are not
ethical other states as was mentioned
our neighbors Massachusetts and Vermont
Arizona California Colorado Maryland New
Mexico New York Oregon and Washington
all B East killing contest wrong message
to our youth as I said the wildlife
killing contest send a wrong message to
our young people they are desensitizing
them and giving them and teaching them
that killing as many animals as you can
is acceptable given the unsettling times
we are living in these days we should be
focused on teaching the Next Generation
to respect all forms of life instead of
killing as much as they can the right
thing to do doing the right thing is
often the wrong thing for those who do
not respect the law or care about why
life public sentiment many people in our
entire Society throughout this country
view these contests as inhumane and
unethical Banning them would reflect the
evolving public sentiment toward
Wildlife Conservation uh conservation
and would be a message support from you
in the state of New
Hampshire
YouTube I had the misp pleasure of
watching a YouTube video on this topic
and during this topic it was a 20 it was
a 48 hour period
these contests were held for bragging
rights a large cash prize or in some
case an assault rifle loaded up with all
the fancy options comments on the video
range from enjoyable it's the thrill I
got to use my AR-15 with night vision or
it's a tradition when we get together to
go out and kill as many animals as we
can to get as many animals as they can
animals are often killed at night with
the use of an assault rifle they may be
baited and trapped and then killed how
is that considered a sport I can't even
comprehend that I did attach which you
probably seen two articles that are not
pleasant to look at but they do
illustrate the reality of what happening
in these contests I believe they would
be beneficial if if you would uh
beneficial to read if you for you to
decide on this matter in speaking to a
point that was raised earlier not
knowing if these pitches are from New
Hampshire or not they don't have to be
we can stop it before they
are I've been around long enough to
understand that there are two sides of
every story in this case the only other
side I can think of is the total lack of
respect for wildlife in one's thrill of
killing Mr chairman and distinguished
committee members I respectfully ask
that you consider enacting legislation
such as House Bill 589 that bans these
contests I also hope you'll do the right
thing by having the Hampshire join the
10 states and become the 11th state to
put an end to these contests thank you
for listening to me I appreciate your
support and thank you for your service
to our great state thank you are there
any
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony today
the chair calls Micah
borers hi there everybody thank you for
listening to me um I'm micaa borers from
Tilton um and I'm here in support of uh
HP 589 so um today you are considering a
law prohibiting killing contests and
want and waste in our state it's my
opinion these contests are far Far Cry
from ethical hunting I believe they
incentivize sadism and Foster especially
in our young people a dismissive and
disrespectful attitude towards wildlife
and life in general as you probably know
deer hunting is highly regulated versus
the take of furbearers like foxes and
coyotes presently the coyote season is
open year round even during pop rearing
season and neither coyote or Fox have
bagging limits although some of fishing
games officials would have you believe
both species populations are abundant
there's a dir of hard data to support
this claim and as a matter of fact
trapping results indicate a possible
decline in red and gray fox these
results are all we have to go off of
since no further research has been
conducted um I did hand out some papers
so you should have those graphs actually
um knowing this our state's current
management of foxes and coyotes is at
best uninformed and Reckless imagine if
Hunters went in the woods to shoot as
many deer as they could dragged them all
back to count and stack in a pile and
some guy was handed a new gun in 100
bucks for killing the most deer out of
everyone else then all the bodies were
left to rot in the woods imagine the
outcry fishing game would not allow that
because they understand it's a huge
waste of life and resources and would
have detrimental impacts on the deer
population but that's exactly what they
do to coyotes and
foxes in my high school ethics class I
developed the philosophy that although
the consequences of our actions are not
Inc consequential the majority of the
moral activity occurs on the
motivational level why do people kill
Wildlife well folks kill deer to feed
their families but people kill coyotes
because they're misinformed or just
because they want to kill something and
worst of all sometimes just because they
hate them killing contests are one of
the worst symptoms of a greater disease
a wrong headed hateful attitude towards
carnivores especially coyotes and an
unwillingness to extend to them the same
respect and care state agencies afford
other species like white tailed deer it
would be a long- awaited step in the
right direction to prohibit killing
contest and Grant our state's essential
Predators a little more respect thank
you so much for
listening thank you for your time are
there any
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony today
the chair calls Bob
Switzer uh Mr chairman members of the
committee my name's Bob Switzer I'm from
Sullivan New Hampshire I find it hard to
believe that in this day and age we have
leg we have to we need legislation to
prevent the want and destruction of
wildlife because of a sporting event
what kind of message does this end when
the state of New Hampshire supports
killing contests how does this reflect
on the rest of the Hunting
Community this reminds me of the
slaughter of bison in the 19th century
when tens of thousands of them were
killed from trains on the Prairie I
would hope that we might have learned a
lesson from this but apparently some
members of our society have not has
anyone determined the purpose of a
killing contest who benefits from it how
does it improve our society I personally
think killing contest condone some of
the most disgusting and detestable
behavior in our society this is nothing
more than thrill killing it takes a
troubled individual to participate in
this kind of activity when a child kills
an animal for fun we fear Mental
Illness but when an adult with the
capacity to reason kills multiple
animals for fun we call it a sport
I've seen the photos of piles of dead
coyotes with grinning a grinning
individual proudly looking into the
camera these dead coyotes are not
utilized in any way and are left to rot
how many of these animals had Young Who
now have to fend for themselves and
possibly die from starvation predation
or exposure all as a result of a killer
who doesn't care about
wildlife speaking specifically about
coyote killing contests The Vermont fish
and wildlife department has said coyote
killing contests are not only
ineffective at controlling coyote
populations but these kinds of
competitive coyote hunts are raising
concerns on the part of the public and
could possibly jeopardize the future of
hunting and affect access to private
lands for all Hunters Vermont as has
been said by other testimony Vermont ban
coyote contest in 2018 and Manchester
banned uh man Massachusetts banned in
2019 and nationally there are 10 states
that have banned them and I think it's
time that New Hampshire joined the rest
of those States in conclusion I ask that
you vote to move this bill out of
committee and send it to the full house
for a vote thank you for your time thank
you are there any
questions seeing none thank you for your
time today
chair calls Christina
Snider good afternoon my name is
Christina Snider I'm from Chester New
Hampshire thank you for listening to my
testimony today I will say that I am in
support of this bill I do support a
banon killing contest and there are
photos of a New Hampshire killing
contest that are currently still public
on Facebook if anybody wants to see them
so they they they are they are there for
New Hampshire but I want to touch on W
and waste a little
bit um I want to talk about crows now a
lot of farmers uh do not like crows and
they kill a lot of crows because they
affect their
corn if this bill passes that would
still be happening they have every right
to protect their property and their
livestock and their crops however there
is a contingent of hunters that go out
and just kill crows just to kill them
and I do have a couple quotes from a
couple articles and these articles they
interviewed a hunter a crow Hunter so
this is not an animal activist this is
someone who shoots crows is an expert at
calling in Crows and shooting them so if
I may I'm going to read these two
quotes shot crows usually are tossed on
manure piles ground into dog food or
left for scavengers because most states
don't set bag limits for Crows Hunters
bragging rights lie in the numbers this
is an article from ESPN regarding New
Hampshire Crow hunting so this is New
Hampshire there's another quote I mean
I'm a Hunter I'm a fisherman and I have
no problem with hunting but Crow hunting
is very different crows are killed and
they're just left or piled up sometimes
it's not that typical hunting where
you're out to gather a resource which
you can enjoy and eat although I'll tell
you they taste great so you can eat
these crows but apparently this is a
crow Hunter and he's calling out a
contingent of The Hunting Community that
just piles up crows tosses them and
they're done that's unacceptable and I
believe that this bill would address
that it should address that that is
clearly an example of killing just for
the sake of killing and I don't think in
2025 that that should be happening not
in my state of New Hampshire and that's
all I have to say thank you thank you
are there any
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony
today chairman calls Ray Green
good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee my name is Ray green I
live in Milford New Hampshire but I am
also the fishing
game um chairman of the fishing Game
Commission and I am the chairman I am
the commissioner for hillsbro
County originally when this bill came
out one thing that I want to make clear
on the commission is the commission
voted opposed to this bill the reason
why we voted opposed to this bill is
that we felt this bill should have been
split into two
bills it's two different
subjects you have want and waste and you
also have killing contests the
commission is not against want and waste
I don't know anybody to want especially
Sportsmen that want to go out and waste
an animal just for the sake of killing
it or to leave it there and not use
it so we're in favor of want and waste
we don't we want want and waste in there
that people aren't wasting it what we're
against is that originally when the bill
started was about
the the wildlife killing
contests the way the original Bill
started you and I could not even have a
bet if we were going to go out on say
Thanksgiving and shoot a turkey and
whoever gets the biggest turkey wins the
other one I use the example you'll serve
dinner because the original bill it said
it couldn't be with two people or more
didn't Define it then it got defined
down even more where it has brought the
bill down quite a bit but the one of the
one of the things that I feel and what
the commission is about is
that the bill is now saying no later
than January 1st the executive director
shall adopt in pursuant to RSA you're
making it just one person is making that
decision what we find out about that is
we have a fantastic director in place
right now but what happens if he is down
the road we have a director in place
that they believe and go out and have a
hunting contest on everything that moves
out there or if you had a director that
came in place and says I don't
believe that this should be any type of
a hunting contest you're leaving it down
to one person making the decision for
how many people that live in the state
that I believe the bill should read with
with the executive director along with
the
approval of the fishing Game Commission
it's the fishing game Commissioners that
are out there with the public hearing
the public meeting with the
public and dealing with the
wildlife and that's all I'm going to
have to say the other just sorry there
is one
more this bill isn't isn't about a
resource
it doesn't affect our resource this bill
is a social
issue you have people that don't believe
oh we shouldn't have a hunting contest
we shouldn't have this that I believe
that is just it's not it's not
about a resource I believe it's it's a
social issue it's kind of one of those
it's a feel-good
bill but what does it really affect
and that's all I have Mr chair thank you
representative Harvey so um the
amendment I believe leades it up to the
ru making process which is um certainly
not one person because when you
do
correct um when you do rules you have
hearings throughout the whole state and
then bring that information back am am I
incorrect In how that rule making
process works and in the ru making
process it also depends what the rule is
on on whether or not the commission has
Authority or not it's not saying hey the
commission has full Authority on all rul
making it comes down
into the the numerous amounts of
sections that the commission does have
Authority or doesn't have authority what
you're doing here is you're not giv the
commission the authority to say what
animals should be on that list
of of a contest or not and the other
thing is defining the
animal so I'm still follow up thank you
I'm
sorry I'm still confused but on a higher
level
so if
we pass such an
amendment and allow this um decision to
be made through the rul making process
process does
that
totally um totally bar the commission
from having any input into that Ru
making process I I'm still confused
about that process I guess well if you
if you pass this as a law the law will
state that the executive director shall
adopt the
rules does doesn't say anything about
the commission you've eliminated the
commission any further
questions representative
Durkin thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so it's been
asked a couple times haven't really got
an answer you might know the answer to
this are there any hunting contests in
the state that you know
of I am not aware of any thank you
any further
questions seeing none thank you for your
time today thank you Mr
chairman chair calls Kurt nberg from the
Humane
Society thank you
sir good afternoon Mr chairman members
of the committee I'm Kurt aronberg I'm
the New Hampshire state director of the
Humane Society of the United States
um uh so I live in
Portsmouth and we are in full support
the Humane Society of the United States
is in full support of a ban on Wildlife
killing contest in the state and we do
support HB
589 uh as originally introduced we would
have liked to have
seen uh some improvements
that ensure that the species that are
most commonly targeted such as coyotes
Etc are more explicitly included in the
language and second we ask that there
are not loopholes in and any exemptions
that might allow some killing contests
to
continue um the
proposal to have the bill
ask for and say shall the commission or
the director
shall um promate
rules we're not necessarily comfortable
with that because of what it says in the
bill
is identifying ex
exemptions except we're allowed by rules
uh made under paragraph two and they
identif identifying exemptions that are
not
specified so it leaves a lot of room
that we're not comfortable with but what
we are comfortable with is effective
language that would ban killing contests
in New Hampshire and I would just say
and there's been a lot said and I don't
want to keep everyone here longer than
they need to be I think there's been a
lot of good information a lot of good
people have testified here today and I
appreciate all the test testimony we've
heard but this measure would not affect
in any way the lawful regulated hunting
control or management of the wildlife
species listed
therein nor would it prevent New
Hampshire land over owners or livestock
Farmers from lethally removing Predators
or animals on their property that are
predators it would merely prohibit
making a cash and prizes game out of the
mass killing of the wildlife that is
managed in trust for the benefit of all
New Hampshire residents and I think the
question we can put to bed today if we
ask the fish and game department are
there contests like this going on in New
Hampshire you'll get the answer um from
the source that knows and uh I think you
should find that out today and I
appreciate uh your time I've cut my
testimony way down I app I uh hope you
appreciate that Mr chairman for time's
sake I'm happy to take any
questions any
questions thank you thank you Mr
co-chair and thank you for taking my
question are you saying that you like
this bill but you want it to be revised
so that it speaks more to
the some of of the points that you're
making about well if the bill Bill's
intention is
to stop the practice of wildlife killing
contests in the state of New Hampshire
we believe that the language should be
clear about that not only about the
species that it protects and covers but
also making sure that if it's done
through rul making or statute or
whatever that it it
is Ironclad in that it it it prohibits
these contests which as I said are
clearly just for cash pleasure prizes um
it's shameful and we shouldn't do it in
New Hampshire thank
you any other
questions seeing none thank you for your
time today thank
you the chair calls uh Chris shadler
good afternoon thank you for allowing me
to speak my name is Chris shadler um I I
have um taught in my life at UNH it's
predominant career in the natural resour
resources department I've also been a
sheep Farmer for 18 years um I have
begun I began 40 years ago with wolf
work and when I moved East realized what
we had here with the Eastern coyote was
a much more interesting animal and so
for the last 30 years I have devoted my
a lot of my life to understanding this
animal to keeping this animal off of my
sheep um the animal has taught me a
great deal about how to be a diligent
farmer etc etc and I'm telling you this
by way of saying that I approach this
pragmatically um I have a science
background and so I add that into the
mix um for 40 years I have traveled all
over New England educating people
primarily on Eastern coyotes but now
also Eastern wolves since we know that
they are part of the mix out
there today we're talking about a bill
to ban Wildlife killing contests and I
think that most of you are probably
saturated with the facts that have
already been presented so I just want to
make a couple of points here um and a
couple of them in response to what Mr
Green was claiming um there were last
minute amendments to this bill and I
think all of you have a copy of those
amendments which allows um requires the
approval of the Commission in Ru making
so the commission of course would be
involved in this the fact that the
executive
director would have the charge once the
bill is in place I'm imagining that
other executive directors that might
follow her would have to um oblige the
law which would be that the The Killing
contests have been
banned another thing and which I find
very
curious I know that there's killing
contests out there maybe I travel with
the wrong crowd but um I know that there
have been two in the very recent past I
don't know about this year uh one near
Jaffrey the other in Rochester I've
heard from some people who know that
there have also been contests up North
so they're happening and it's surprising
to me that
that more people aren't aware um it's
not all it's also not surprising to me
that some of the contests that had been
occurring have
gone have been occurring without a lot
of advertising let's put it that way um
the public is aware because of me and
other groups who have been talking about
the ludicrous nature of holding a
contest that actually encourages people
to kill the most animals that they can
kill and if you would just look at the
testimony that is before you my
testimony the front page looks like
this it has a little chart on the
bottom and that
chart if you can take a look at it the
chart indicates from fishing and game
data that that red fox gray fox and
Fisher are in trouble in our
state they are in
trouble why they're in trouble in part
because of hunting in part because of
rodenticides in part because of habitat
change these
predators are a little bit more
specialized than prey species are and so
um when we as a state allow or turn our
eye away from contests that do this it
is it amounts to
indiscriminate killing of predator
species and somebody wanted to know
which species red fox gray fox coyote
Fisher
raccoon just killed and stacked up way
made measured and
discarded I also want to say Mr Green
made the point about separating want and
waste from killing contests killing
contests generate want and
waste they are
quintessentially united together
so in our view and and hopefully the
folks at fishing game agree or might see
that this bill the way that it's written
needs to be written in exactly this way
so that we understand what want and
waste is and that want and waste results
from indiscriminate killing of wild
animals the last thing I'm going to say
oh no sorry the last thing I'm going to
say is that there's a principle involved
here the principle of respecting the
wildlife that we have and several people
have talked about this I think it's
really important I don't regard it as a
social issue I regard it very much as a
wildlife um an issue that is affecting
our wildlife and because so many tens of
thousands of tourists come to our state
now and spend their money to see our
wildlife and to see the natural beauty
of the place why not care for these
animals in this very simple way it's
certainly not a bill about hunting we we
are as a coalition oh so I founded the
New Hampshire wildlife Coalition along
with John harrian and our view was that
protector that Predators needed
protection um for a variety of reasons
and anyway that's basically what I
wanted to say to you I hope that you
will support this bill it's a good bill
it's about time 10 other states have
done it I know how independent New
Hampshire is but the tide is turning
against these things
thank you thank you any questions
representative love
it thank you Mr chair could could you
just explain on your graph what we're
talking about in 2024 with regard to Red
Fox gray fox um what what does that
little bullet tell us in terms of the
trend well you can see numerically oh I
or vaguely or you're the scientist you
tell us what we have means could
question on the Coalition we have Wen
Bosworth who's our statistician and what
he did was he took the um the record the
Trapper records from fishing game over a
long period of time to see whether these
animals are in a stable State and what
these bullet points represent is a
decline overtime in their
population in terms of the actual
numbers what's interesting about these
numbers and I'm glad you asked is that
people are not responsible fishing game
doesn't hold them responsible for
reporting what they've killed so all we
know is what Trappers are able to take
and so what we're seeing here is is a
measure in that
way thank you any other questions
representative
tutor so the the graph the numbers that
the graph represents are the numbers of
fox is taken by Trappers they yes
essentially follow up Mr chair follow up
again thank you for taking my question
um isn't it also true that we've had a
severe reduction in Trappers over the
same period yeah it is no well trapping
same number of trapping LIC oh same
number of trapping licenses I don't same
number of
Trappers that's a good question for
fishing game okay thank you any
questions representative Durkin thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question uh is is there any way that you
could determine that that those numbers
are shrinking because of overt trapped
hunted or because of
losing uh their habitat y I think that's
such a good question and it gets to the
complexity of the issue there's no
there's no one single thing that is
impacting wildlife in our our state it's
it's a matter of all of it
and one could argue and people have
argued that killing contests being so
indiscriminate provide what they call
additive
mortality to a situation where these
animals are also facing loss of habitat
poisoning with rodenticides all of those
things are coming into play here
I'm not I I'm honestly not avoiding your
question it's a great question the
answer really is very
complex um and I I am not certain that
there has been enough research on on on
exactly this um more research would be
better and finally I think UNH has
finally got a guy in Maul Remington that
is interested in doing the research
thank you any other
questions seeing none thank you for your
time okay thank you very much the chair
calls Kyle
Baker good afternoon I'm Kyle Baker here
wath young and patali here I'm behalf of
New Hampshire Wildlife Federation New
Hampshire Wildlife Federation is a nonon
nonprofit
um that's here to advocate for Hunting
Fishing trapping as well as the
conservation of land for increased
access to hunt fish and trap um so as
the bill is written um we have some
concerns with the piece of legislation
um similar to Mr Green we believe the
issue should be split um if we want to
have a discussion about a clear concise
and enforcable definition of what want
and waste is um I think Sporting
Community would be all for that um you
know we talked about search and rescue
this morning you rarely hear about
hunters needing search and rescue
services in New Hampshire but when you
do it's that hunter that took one more
step into the bog to pull the duck out
or took a little bit too took a little
bit too far of a walk into into a body
of water to try to find their deer um
Hunters care deeply about reducing W and
waste um I do I did just saw this
amendment um this afternoon um I think
it does make a a small amount of
improvement to the bill particularly
giving those at the department some Ru
making Authority um I do still have a
considerable amount of concern with the
sort of the broadness of the definition
of want and waste and we want to see
spend some time with it and see if we
can't find uh you know a a more a more
concise and more easily enforceable
definition um for everyone to follow
regarding hunting contests um we feel
that if we have a clear definition of
what want and waste is um set through
the department using using their
background um the idea of a killing
contest or hunting contest um would be
moot um because we would ensure that
there would already be laws on the books
to to prohibit the want and waste of of
animals so um we also have concerns
about whether or not um the the amended
language here the amendment that we're
looking at this afternoon would start to
apply to things like fishing deres or
buck pools or things that aren't
necessarily what I think the intentions
are of the sponsor um when it comes to
you know contests that involve you know
harvesting the highest amount of animals
Forces versus the heaviest Buck or the
largest trout through the ice or things
along those lines so um we think the
bill needs does need a consider able
amount of work um but we're happy to um
provide input as the process
continues thank you any questions
representative
Harvey thank thank you Mr chair thank
you uh Mr Baker
um please correct me if I'm wrong but
didn't we pass the house didn't we pass
a um a Prohibition on killing contest
last week last week um last session and
and this and the body on the other side
of the wall did not approve of that
no uh I'm not aware of that I believe in
2020 there was a very similar piece of
legislation to this um and it did work
its way through the Senate process I
think they had removed the hunting
contest piece and created a senator
Waters I believe worked on it had a
smaller a more concise definition of
want and waste and I believe that passed
the Senate but then the world shut down
and I don't think anything it didn't
make it out the other side oh co co
happened I'm seeing Mr Bosworth shake
his head thank you
y any other questions seeing none thank
you for your time today
the chair recognizes the last speaker
Colonel
Jordan good afternoon Mr chair members
of the committee again I'm Kevin Jordan
I'm the colonel at New Hampshire fishing
game um so I check marked that we're in
favor of this bill um but I do have some
caveats to that so we worked we tried
the director and I tried or did work
actually with Welden and Chris shadler
and had some success in trying to reach
uh their goals without compromising
Sportsmen and women that are doing it
the right way and they're I can tell you
those numbers far out way the numbers
you're hearing about today uh and I can
say that because I'm the guy that
prosecutes those people so we do have a
few and and I think New Hampshire has
done a real good job I think you your
reference to the cruelty bill was a good
example Mr chairman when we worked
together uh that was a good example of
getting together with folks on both
sides of the aisle and I and frankly
listening to the speakers and some of
them did a tremendous job I don't think
we're that far apart on our beliefs I
don't think animals should be wasted
either um it makes me very angry that's
why I do this job is because I love
animals but I also hunt and fish and I
love that very much when it's done right
I think it's a great thing and I I will
disagree that children shouldn't be
involved I think we should should go out
of our way to make sure the children are
involved because I think it's a safer
environment than what a lot of kids are
exposed to today so but we can debate
that on a different day we did talk to
Chris shayler and and Welden and we were
concerned about Buck con deer contest
because deer contests don't really
matter people are still going to take
deer they're going to hunt deer and and
uh Harvest them um and businesses there
are a lot of deer pools across the state
businesses use it to generate business
um whether we have those contests or not
people are still going to harvest deer
and you can choose whether or not you
ever want to participate in it um we
were concerned about the rotary fishing
derby and other derbies that have a
great impact on the local economy and
bring families and and if you didn't go
to that Derby this year it was kind of
refreshing to see the family groups out
there the kids out there playing on
sleds and and the fathers fishing it was
kind of nice again I think personally
it's something Society needs more of um
and so anytime we can promote that
that's good and they were very open to
that discussion that that is not what
their intent was in my opinion um and so
we worked pretty hard with 11
Commissioners to try and and get 11
Commissioners on board uh to try and
meet as many of the goals as we could as
the prime sponsor and the folks that
support this bill and not interfere with
hunting and so that took a while
including up until uh as late as this
morning I typed a um a suggested
Amendment it's not an amendment it's a
suggestion and that's I think was
delivered to the clerk and has red
language in it and basically the
amendment that we started with today has
several faults to it it will be
unenforceable on a couple of different
fronts and I want to make sure
everyone's aware of that and that was
the reason that we submitted this
amendment so first off um and I think my
director actually did this uh by mistake
but under want and waste under line five
if you look she says the Act of
intentionally knowingly recklessly or
with criminal negligence so what she's
trying to describe there a criminal
culpable mental States uh intentionally
is not a a culpable mental state in the
state of no Hampshire it's not
recognized not defined so it can't exist
in a law you can't use it um and we
wouldn't use culpable mental States in a
violation level offense it puts the
level of proof much higher and
unnecessary so the one that I crafted I
basically eliminated that by replacing
the language with the act of wasting a
wild animal or a wild bird period that's
all you have to prove it's much easier
uh to do that the second part of this is
they refer to animal throughout this
bill there no legal is crazy there's no
legal definition for animal in in our
chapter so we described animals as wild
animals there's a great definition for
that there's a great definition for wild
uh Birds uh and there's a there's is a
all-encompassing def definition of
wildlife which includes reptiles
amphibians all animals so anywhere that
the the amendment had animals I replaced
it with wild animal or wild bird the
final change I put in and the commission
told me that this would be required for
their approval was no l if you drop down
on um where we're instructing the
executive director to adopt rules I put
a space in there the ex Ive director
shall adopt excuse me the executive
director with the approval of the
commission shall adopt rules pursuant to
541a meaning the commission would have
to approve those rules to move forward
and then uh uh representative Harvey
you're absolutely correct it would be
public hearings so there would be a lot
of time for input there would be a lot
of time for making adjustments uh and
then you come over here to JL car which
I know you all are familiar where where
there's another shot at that or another
bite at that Apple so
we would prefer I believe we would would
have preferred the bills to be split we
quite frankly I've been told by my my
new director that we're going to come up
with a want and waste description and
Rule whether this law passes or not we
think it's important I think she's she's
I think this is a good description I
think the prime sponsor did an excellent
job um trying to trying to hone that
down I think it will protect Hunter
there's the provisions are in this bill
in the amended version I did and in her
amended version there's Provisions in
there for land owners there's which will
exclude them they can protect their
property there's there's Provisions in
there or will be in the rule for
nuisance Wildlife for animal controller
all of those things will be considered
that's the advantage to doing it in rule
is it gives us the opportunity to custom
make that so we don't interfere across
lines that we don't want to cross so if
if in fact the the prime sponsor and
everyone here agreed uh with this
version with the with the red piece that
I put in the commission has instructed
me they would support it and we would
too um so just for your own information
we are going to create want and waste in
rule whether this bill passes or not New
Hampshire's long overdue for that 12
other states have done it I've looked at
them all um and they and I think it's an
important thing to do and we can do it
as easily as we did the cruelty um I
will tell you this you know I caution
people all the time about social media
we make cas is all the time based on
social media I hate it frankly my own
opinion I hate it I think it's
ridiculous and wasteful and I really
want to caution people for believing
what you see on it I think a lot of
times those I know those videos are made
up because I've investigated them and
they don't they don't they're not they
don't run out the facts so and they're
upsetting and I feel bad about that I
don't want people thinking that that
kind of activity goes on I will argue I
don't think New Hampshire is
slaughtering animals if they're doing it
they're hiding it and they're doing a
good job of it and I'll give you a good
example I had an officer who took a
young officer the other day took a duck
a goose carcass and a turkey carcass he
no longer needed it was used in a case
he drove out on the Sea Coast into a
field that he thought was very remote he
dumped the carcass within the hour I
received a call at headquarters about
these two dump carcasses and that
someone should investigate that cuz
someone shot these things illegally so I
find it hard to believe that we're
shooting truckloads of coyotes and
dumping them in the woods I think I
would know that I think I would get that
call unfortunately if we don't put
something in place that could happen I
think it could happen and then the other
question I want to answer for you the
wildlife contest in the states there are
a lot of deer pools as I've said I'm
aware of a lot of turkey pools that go
on that are open I knew of two coyote
contests one uh in the Rochester area no
longer exists I don't know why but it
doesn't um and then another individual
who I believe just aged out of of doing
this kind of thing but here's something
else I want you to think about the one
good thing about poachers is they they
can't help themselves they want the
world to know thank goodness because
that's how they get caught they're not
going to shoot the biggest coyote in the
state of New Hampshire and keep it a
secret they are not going to do that and
that's why we catch them when they do
those things they're going to post it
they're going to take pictures of it
they're going to share it so I really
believe if these things were rampid we
would know about it uh we would have
some indication of it I think in New
Hampshire it could exist cuz we don't
have anything to prevent it and I think
if we work together all of us if we were
have passed this the way the way we've
adjusted it we could come up with rules
that might not please everyone but I
don't think it would interfere with
Hunters like this might passing it just
the way it is or doing it all in law I
think allowing it to be done in rule
will give people an opportunity to do
that thank you that's all I have sir
representative Harvey actually Mr chair
this is a question for you um I started
the morning out quite organized and then
it it disappeared discombobulated yes
that do we have his Amendment yes it's
the one with
red and I apologize for
that oh I think actually I think only
the three up here got it we'll we'll get
copies not a problem okay um I can pass
mine over to you so you can look at it
if you like
I don't have anything in
red pass that over
sorry any actual questions for the
colonel representative
tutor thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question that I was just
reading the amendment and it came to a
question that I asked one of the
presenters earlier let me just read you
what the amendment says and ask your
question you can tell me whether you
think you'd arrest me yes sir um want
way shall include the removal of the
head hide tail or antas from a game
animal and leaving the edible portion to
waste yes so if I shoot a fox and take
the fur and leave the meat in my that
would not be that would not be wanting
waste in my opinion I've left the I've
took the hide Y and left them want and
waste would be um you we had an
individual shooting moose cutting the
ear off and leaving the rest of the
animal on the ground or guys
taking I shouldn't say guys people
taking shooting deer at night taking the
hind quarter and leaving the rest of the
animal in the wood that's want and waste
um I think and and understand this
whenever you guys know this whenever you
create a law you can't bulletproof it
and it comes down to officer discretion
and I'm confident that we have some good
officers that use good discretion so
things like that would be would be taken
into consideration yes and I will tell
you the other thing that bothered me
running coyotes down with snow machines
I'm going to tell you something I will
prosecute them and there are good laws
on the books to do that that is illegal
method of take that is harassment
Wildlife that could border on cruelty of
Wildlife and I would never tolerate an
act like that we we make cases on people
running over intentionally running over
Wildlife turkeys are the biggest one
they'll see a flock they get sick of
them being in a road and they'll drive
through them and we' made cases on that
multiple times multiple times just like
the Flaming moose yeah it's not you're
not going to to I'm not well not no
one's going to tolerate that most
coyotes I've run into would be pretty
would get away from the snow machine
pretty quick yeah any other questions
representative Smith I'm not saying it
wouldn't happen I'm saying we wouldn't
tolerate it there's a there's a
difference there thank you Mr chairman
and thank you Colonel excuse me for
taking my question I you you didn't hit
on this but I think it's important for
you to elaborate in the want and waste
definition where it talks about without
making a reasonable effort to retrieve
Salvage and render it I know reasonable
is very subjective yes what's reasonable
to one officer is might not be to
another absolutely it's is that going to
be left up to a field determination I
mean who's going to make that decision
we we debated that a lot for that very
reason so to me that common sense is
reasonable a reasonable effort would be
someone who who would not just shoot and
turn and walk away he would make some
effort to and most hunters do they go to
Great Lengths to to uh and and Kyle BR
brought up a good point a lot of the
hunters that we search for are actually
looking for deer when they get lost so
um but I think in rule we would have to
work on defining that a little better
for our judges cuz I want to make sure
the judges are on board so I think there
would have to be a little further
definition of that this wouldn't if
we're if we're and this uh sponsor
representative that brought the Schultz
who I've never met I really appreciate
you bringing this representative she if
she's doing what we ask she's she's
trying to give us the authority to do it
in rule so it's not real clear here with
the idea it will be cleared up in Rule
and I I would agree with that that's the
way to do that and I'll tell the the
other thing as you know if we do
something in Rule and it doesn't work
and we have to revisit it if it's in law
it takes two years to and a lot of
issues with rule we can do it almost
immediately we can fix it so that's why
we wanted to do it in rule but that need
work representative
Khan thank you Mr chairman thank you
Corell taking my question so we heard
from uh U chairman of the ficient Game
Commission that we he doesn't know that
we have any competition in the state of
New Hampshire if I heard it right and
also you said that you know the uh the
won animal West you know uh the
commission is going to change the rule
in future near future because you think
that that's needed to be my director
wants to do that yes and I and I'm on
board with that we I in my opinion we
have to run that by the commission but I
believe the commission wants that as
well so my question is you know if
everybody is in the same page we don't
have a problem and we going to change it
through our you existing rule why we
need a new law for this
purpose well I think that I now I'm
speaking to what I think they
think putting myself in their shoes I
think they want to make sure it's done
and so putting it in
law makes it happen I personally I think
it would be done without it but but I
think the reason that they I think
originally they weren't going to put it
in Rule and then we convinced them to
change this to putting it allowing us to
put it in
rule thank follow thank you uh Corell so
we are doing that we thinking that uh in
future we might have a problem and we
are preemptively making a
law I don't know that I can say that I
don't know that I can say that I I don't
know that the problem is I don't I don't
agree the problem is ramp it um I I
don't I don't know what I think about
that any other
questions seeing none thank you sir the
chair will now close the hearing on uh
57 589
FN and we will move and can the rest of
the committee get I took a picture we're
going to get a copy okay made okay okay
yeah I took a picture but um we will get
a copy made but first I need to open
this and then the the clerk can run out
with a request for a copy thank you I'm
going to now move directly into uh
opening the public hearing on HB 545
FN I recognize the prime sponsor Jack
Flanigan representative Flanigan my
mistake m kalpa
he can sit next to you we'll actually
consider you both testifying at the same
time if that's fine and that'll save us
some
time although I'm running behind by an
hour I do strive for efficiency
thank you Mr chairman uh for the
record should we give it a minute
here there you go um for the record uh
my name is Jack Flanigan I represent
Hillsboro 45 which is a florial of four
towns Hallis Brookline Mason and
Greenville four towns that are border
towns I suppose with the state of
Massachusetts um I introduced this this
piece of legislation after meeting Mr
zil Felder here next to me who has asked
uh I've asked him to be part of this
because I've known him for 30 years from
other activities but he's the one that
sort of got me into this servid issue
basically
CWD um the um Mr zelder is very
knowledgeable about it he uh as some
people might have habits of her interest
of you know photography or fishing or
whatever I won't talk about the previous
bill
his interest is deer and other
servants but when he told me about CWD
and the impact on animals health and
potentially human health I thought
well you know how do we make sure this
doesn't happen and he says well New
Hampshire's been pretty good um but also
other states are not so good as far as
CWD and I think he has some information
as it relates to the frequency of it but
then it was well I knew people that
would go hunting in other other states
and bring the deer back and they said
well how do we make sure that they don't
bring back
CWD because in talking to Mr zelder it
can be spread from the stool of the
animal uh or if it was a tick uh the
tick could spread the disease too so
he's got more detail in it but the
reality is is we've got to make sure
that if we bring
animal the harvested animal into the
state that we're not bringing the
disease in with it so uh Mr chairman
I'll take any questions you may have of
me but I like I said the technical part
that's why I brought him along hand it
right
over um and I'm not an expert by any
means I just I I do have an interest in
Deer
um
I probably was a little bit foolish and
about 5 years ago I set some alerts and
every every single article published on
PubMed and Google Scholar on CWD is is
sent to me just because of my interest
in things um right now there's currently
36 states that owledge
CWD how many copies do we have there
there's like six there but I can provide
anything we can we can provide a link Mr
chairman um one thing I just wanted to
talk about quickly is uh like cancer and
pregnancy you can either have cancer or
you don't you are either pregnant or you
aren't cancer untreated the disease
progresses and of course if you let a
pregnancy continue it goes to
termination I I bring that up because
the same for
CWD like DNA testing testing for CWD has
got a lot better in recent years
there are things that we do now that I
believe in um removing the head before
you bring a serve it in from other
states because of the preal prevalency
of the infected prons in the brain but
we know that is most common later
stages um even though Wildlife agencies
try to pin the blame on captive herds
there are far more confirmations in hter
harvested or roadkill servid and again I
want to make sure that it's known that
I'm not anti fishing game I'm not
hunting I don't have a horse in this
race a bunch of my friends hunt I
understand the sport in the passion and
don't want to interfere with that he
just asked me to speak on some facts so
anyway far more confirmations in Hunter
harvested or Road killed servid than
captive
Farms the the
current um New Hampshire fishing game p
this side instead doesn't
matter we I I told them to make 20 but I
don't think we did I
didn't so the current fishing game
published CW information lacks
detail it does not acknowledge that
prons are misfolded proteins and are
detectable in all tissues tested
including muscle before so so I remember
Mr chairman a conversation when you you
thought that CWD was only in the brain
as far as testing all the research is
now showing that it's it's a blood
related illness gotcha not not only is
it in all the tissues of the infected
cids but you can pull a tick from an
infected servid and find the infect
just so the committee knows all these
copies are going to the clerk and she'll
make copies for
everybody in my real work I've worked at
very high-end professional motorcycle
racing all over the world and I've come
to understand in certain areas you work
with the absolute leaders in those areas
and I've in my interest on this I'm also
communicating with researchers all over
the world on this
disease um this is an example of
one um in
communicating with him I had a
question I asked about could CWD be
detected in myoglobin myoglobin when we
cook a steak most people think the red
juice is blood but that's a
myoglobin I said if not same question
for any of the parts that would be
harvested in hunting
activities his response was I'm not sure
if anybody has examined myoglobin
products for the presence of
CWD we know that not only
muscles but also basically all examined
tissues bodily fluids blood cerebral
spinal fluid saliva and excretions urine
and feces from CWD affected cervids
carry the infected
prons Mr chairman I he was motivated to
bring the the meat along but I think
he's trying to stress my my point is
this infect ious pry it's a misfolded
protein we all understand what protein
is okay I believe there needs to be
regulation around
CWD currently you can't import alive
non-native servage screened for CWD yet
naive people to CWD can go hunt and
potentially bring infected tissues
without any
regulation does anybody here know how
long a servid can go without showing any
signs of
infection it it does and the larger
animals can go 5 years now without any
indication
okay the the point of that is what do a
lot of people want to go out a stay in
Hunt so
again my discussions with Fish and Game
have been about protecting the herd um
this prion is extremely infectious you
cannot incinerate it 1600 Dees won't
kill it um
not everybody likes the taste of cids I
I have an employee that's an avid Hunter
he went to the Midwest shot a servid
that had a very very high diet of sage
and as passionate as he is about honey
he couldn't stand the taste of it when
you throw that away where's it going
what's it doing
potentially you know we're we're
spreading there's there's tests being
done right now on articles clothing
knives boots all all kinds of stuff you
can
prove how how it
moves
um so just one last quick
thing penil Pennsylvania is not the
worst State when it comes to CWD
confirmations but it happens to be close
and they do have a real problem down
there they also have a very good website
with data and you can clearly clearly
this this is real time I printed it
before I left my office this morning you
can clearly see the hunted Hunter
harvested detections are far greater the
roadkill detections are far greater than
anything in a caped
facility another thing Mr chairman too
if I can just interrupt Mr zelder is
that he had provided me a list I I
assume it was a current list of states
that that had active CWD animals that
they stopped um remember they listed the
Colorado had some or Pennsylvania but it
was where was that CWD
dog CWD info. org okay
which it's a very good website it's
known as the website um but there's no
detail there's no real information but
if you go there you will see how
prevalent the confirmations are all over
the place the harvested meat right
primarily yeah
um and again I'm I'm not an expert I'm
just a person that's had a real interest
in this um but but because of all the
information that I received some of the
information that I've had um honestly
CDC
changed uh some information on their
website because of some things and uh
lisiana a couple of years back when they
had their first
confirmation they tried to pin it on
captive herds and it wasn't the case it
was H harvested and they had to correct
the information untested too right
what's that the animals were
untested uh the the herded animals no no
it was a hunter harvested animal that
tested positive the first time around
please try to direct your questions and
comments to the chair and the and the
committee not between your the point is
it it was trying to be deflected in
another area
y thank you is do you have more be open
for questions I don't I'm open for
questions okay are there any questions
representative Harvey um so in reading
the bill um Mr berson from fish and game
last week testified they do know what
states have CWD um doesn't surprise me
Pennsylvania because of its large deer
population but my question is
um if if you're um if you take meat
outside of the
state you need to have a tested for C
CWD prior to bring the meat into New
Hampshire um how would that work I I
don't know how where where would you
take this to have it practiced for for
me that's an excellent question um I
think fishing game should be the driving
force behind that my my point is to show
you
that the information available now is
very different than what it was it's no
different than DNA testing you all know
how that is evolved over the
years um I think with upto-date
information you should make in formed
decisions and that is a big one but if
you are really concerned about
protecting the herd this needs to be
looked at and addressed followup please
followup so I might have to ask this of
fishing game and not you but I'll start
here um does fishing game have a a
procedure for processing
meat uh fish fishing game does oh
um you know there's there's debate
currently on the test currently being
used versus some newer
tests you you need to understand and why
I brought the ground beef is
CWD to me when I first started looking
at it was this
overwhelming subject very very
complicated and as I started talking to
people in reading more and more I
started thinking more about prion
disease in
general most people in this room are
going to remember the late 80s and early
90s the mad cow disease that happened in
Europe that was prion disease in cattle
it happens in cats it honestly can
happen in camel now it's um chronic
wasting disease in cids um it's Scrapy
in Goat
in sheep uh and in humans it's known as
kutzel decob disease and there's several
variants of that at this point um H
honestly like there's one person that
died of uh prion disease in New
Hampshire last year two years ago it was
two three years ago it was
three um one of the things I'd like to
urge this group group is whenever
there's a discussion a debate or a Ru
making process around Pyon disease you
really need to bring some experts in um
New Hampshire was involved in a
very big lawsuit in 2013 because a
person was misdiagnosed here and again
it's extremely infectious and it was
brain surgery and then they used the
equipment on other people not knowing it
Ben crutz Jacob disease
so representative
Durkin thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question
um what are we looking at as far as the
cost for a test and the time for it
again like I would defer to fishing game
last I knew and I believe fishing game
was used in a lab in Pennsylvania for
their tests here it was around $50 for
the type of tests they were doing what I
don't understand is there's an awful lot
of states that provide CWD testing for
free whether that's Federal money I I
don't know again that's not my area but
I would look into those things in and
honestly maybe it needs to be on the
states where the CWD is known to be
prevalent Mr chairman if I could go back
back to the other representative's
question as far as uh the testing was
concerned and we'll get back and please
don't know because I wanted to share too
is rul making will allow uh the fishing
game to decide as it relates to how it's
tested who does the testing and at some
point in time the costs um my goal
though and I fishing game might like it
is I'd rather have the hunter stay in
state than go to another state so if it
does cost a little bit more to get the
the meat tested more Reon to stay in New
Hampshire and get a license to hunt in
New
Hampshire that was one thing that I was
thinking about when I introduced the
bill and I hope that answered your
question go ahead sir I'm sorry follow
up follow up
um so you had said that there were
counts of people having the proton
proton the prons prons so is that are
you telling me that the
CWD has made the crossover from
no the cude no I'm saying pron
diseases exist in several different
species we all know that BSE in cattle
the prion disease in cattle is zuntic
that's why it created I'm sorry what is
what zuntic when it what that what does
that mean when it goes from one species
to another I believe human somebody may
be able to correct me on that um there
there
are that that's a big big subject this
is a lightning rod and my intent is to
not stir that pot he asked me for some
detail okay
um without
question there are tests nonhuman tests
that confirm CWD can cross species
now they haven't done that in a human
yet
but I will tell you that funding doesn't
exist for those
tests last followup thank you Mr uh
chairman so I'm just trying to get this
straight so there are no reported cases
of hunters or anybody who have eaten
served meat coming down with there are
plenty of cases where I didn't get that
could you try again watch
there are plenty of cases that are
suspect um there was actually a girl in
Maine in
1997 that um there's a
CDC scientist Dr ble that researched
that one there's several other cases
where there have been groups in uh
feasts like Hunter harvested feasts you
know a group of 10 people and all of a
sudden two of them die from variant
kutzel Jacob variant is different than
the sporadic form of crutz Feld
Jacob
um that again is a lightning rod I don't
I don't want to get into that that
there's a lot to
protect there um
that's not why I'm here I don't want to
be in the middle of that discussion or
that
debate representative
Khan thank you Mr chairman uh
representative thank you for taking my
questions
uh I'm looking at your bill I cannot
find anywhere it says deer it says
meat oh okay so what my question is if
we you know have to test all this meat
comes into the
near the department need lot of
resources you know it needs a you know
extra Manpower and all these
things uh the the question came up with
o was how do we enforce
it because someone goes to Pennsylvania
or other state that's known
CWD how do we enforce it but you know
the funny thing about hunters and I
think I heard it in the previous bill is
they like to talk about what they
shot so then the question becomes is
amongst the neighbors or other Shooters
did they get it tested and if they
didn't then it will eventually get to
Colonel Gordon or Corner Gordon's crewp
over there um and it'll eventually sort
of work its way through so I think the
issue then becomes is how to enforce it
is I think it'll be self- enforcing
after a while people will know that if
you hunt outside of the State of New
Hampshire and you bring the servant in
that has to be
tested any other
questions seeing none thank you for your
time today thank you Mr chairman and
representatives chair calls Dan berson
New Hampshire fishing
game no problem
thank you I was dying and I'm like I
can't go back there
again um good afternoon Mr chair members
of the committee uh Dan buron I'm the
chief of the wildlife division for New
Hampshire fishing game um I'm here um
for the department and the commission
and opposition of this bill um one point
of clarification so the department
actually already does post a list of CWD
positive jurisdictions on our website
we've been doing that for a number of
years um it's also in our digest with a
reference to to make sure you check the
website because again these positive
States unfortunately pop up fairly
regularly um so we're constantly
updating that list as we as we get word
um the department feels this is um is
unnecessarily restrictive um so we do
have restrictions in regards to what
Hunters are allowed to bring back into
the state um when they harvest a served
so a servid is any member of the deer
family so that's white tail deer moose
mule deer so obviously New Hampshire
it's whail deer and and um and moose but
people go to other states they hunt mu
deer they hunt elk and most of these
animals are susceptible to getting
CWD um our current
restrictions um what you are allowed to
bring back in so so the way we restrict
it is if a hunter goes to a CWD positive
state which they can identify by going
to our website they're allowed to bring
back in deboned meat antlers antlers
attached to skull caps with all the soft
tissue removed um upper canine teeth
with all the soft tissue removed hides
or capes with no parts of the head
attached um finished Taxidermy mounts
and then tissues prepared and packaged
for use by diagnostic Research
Laboratories um we allow these in
because we consider these lowrisk um
tissues um as was stated before um as as
testing methods have evolved over time
and become more sensitive um there's
ways to amplify um amplify the the the
samples um prons are basically
everywhere um they find them in in
virtually every tissue that they've
looked in um they as was referenced they
found them in ticks they also find that
certain plants will take them up in
their Roots um the big question is what
is the risk associ ated with these
preons and what are the different preon
levels um it's not completely welln what
is in you know quote unquote infective
dose of prons if you will um but most
States um consider meat as low risk um
So currently so our our deer project
leader went through and checked all the
regulations in all 50 states um
currently there are no states that
restrict the importation of meat or
require testing of meat um New
Hampshire's import restrictions are
actually a bit more restrictive than
than many other states um other states
allow quartered um deer to come back in
some states have no restriction um you
can bring you can bring anything back in
even if it's a CWD positive State
there's only a handful of those at this
point um but but our current
restrictions are actually more
restrictive than than many other
states um again we're our restrictions
are more focused on these what we
consider high-risk tissues so things
like nervous system tissues um brains
lymph nodes spleen um there's been
research that has shown um there was one
study that showed the preon levels in
muscle tissue was you know 2,000 to
10,000 times less than what they find in
brain tissue um so the current belief
although it is concerning that there
that we are detecting prons and all
these tissues um the the current um the
current knowledge is is that these are
still low-risk tissues and likely not a
big risk R for transmission of the
disease um another difference with
allowing Hunters to bring back
particularly deboned meat um the
assumption is is that that individual is
going to consume that right so you're
already somewhat contained that that
meat comes back and it get it gets
consumed or um in the in the event
someone doesn't like it it doesn't taste
good it goes bad hopefully and and maybe
this is something we should do more
education on but hopefully that
individual would dispose of that in the
garbage um that goes to a landfill which
is actually um an approved method for
disposing of CWD positive known CWD
positive tissues um a lot of states will
landfill um they'll typically landfill
or incinerate to to dispose the to
dispose of positive
tissues
um in in terms of availability of
testing um so again there's there's
constant research going on on better
ways to detect prons um
as these things develop um that's good
there there's they're looking at live
animal tests which is which is positive
um currently none of these other newer
forms of testing have Federal standards
um so we do on an annual basis we do um
CWD surveillance in the state um so our
biologists will collect the heads of
Hunter harvested deer from within New
Hampshire from butchers um we remove
lymph nodes and we send those to a lab
for testing um if those samples if any
of those samples were to come back
positive um they then rerun a sample to
confirm that in fact um there was a
positive and these tests um are all
certified through through USDA um so one
of the issues is one there's there's
really no certified tests for meat at
this time um there's not a lot of um I'm
our our biologist was able to locate one
um facility that did offer testing of
meat um but again there's no federal
standards for that there's no way to um
you know get confirmation of what those
results are um we don't know what weight
times would be so you could run into
instances where um you know a hunter
goes to another state he goes to have
his meat tested you know does that meat
stay in a freezer for weeks or months um
until they find out the results and then
they have to go back to the state to
retrieve the
meat um so so these are all questions we
have of how this would function um
testing um testing is is is pretty
expensive um um particularly if you were
going to consider doing it at that level
and that scale um so so we certainly
have some concerns about how that might
function where Hunters might get the
tests um um the fact that there are no
federal standards for the tests um who's
going to pay for this um all for a
tissue that that currently is considered
low risk for transmission um the the
association of Fish and Wildlife
agencies um which New Hampshire fishing
game is a part of um they have um they
have a document um it's
a it's best man it's a best management
practice document for CWD they still
consider live animal movement um the
greatest risk for CWD so it was
referenced that there's other states and
there's um substantially more um CWD
positive animals found in in wild
animals um and that's true but the
reason for that is there are
substantially more wild animals on the
landscape um there's been many many
documented cases um and they can they
can do this because captive facilities
have to keep records of movement um they
can do Trace back um you know Trace back
from the herd of origin they can track
how this disease has moved around um
from these captive animals um so it's
been very well documented that captive
animals are are the greatest risk for
the spread of of this disease and it
would make sense right because these
animals have all the body tissues
they're alive they're continually
shedding these these proteins into the
environment there's escapes um these
these proteins are um as was referenced
they're very stable they can last in the
environment for years um and and it does
take a while for them to to show
themselves so um one good example um so
New York State um in 2005 um it detected
its first um CWD positive animal in a
captive facility and then in Wild deer
um they spent you know over a million
dollars to do Advanced um culling and
surveillance um they were at the time
believed to be the only state to to
effectively um get rid of CWD as it were
um and just this past year um they found
another positive in a captive facility
um the closest that this has been
detected to New Hampshire was in Quebec
um again in a captive facility um of I
think it was red deer um Quebec spent
millions of dollars to bring in a
company to um call Wild deer around the
captive facility um fortunately they did
not find any CWD um in those in any of
the wild deer um which is a big concern
to us that that um I believe that
facility was only about 100 miles from
New Hampshire um but again it highlights
the the risk of of captive animals um
USDA does do have a certification
program for herds um where um captive
captive served grower would enroll in
this program there's different steps
that they take to reduce the risk um and
they have to be enrolled in this program
for five years to become certified as
low risk um however there are problems
with this with this um um with this
method and um just a highlight so we
looked in there's a US Animal Health
Association committee on Farm sery day
um so in 2021 there were 35 new positive
Farm served herds um of those four of
the herds were enrolled in the in the
certification program and eight were
actually considered certified which
means they had all their animals had not
um had any detectable cases of CWD
within a 5-year period so you can see
how concerning this is um and the lack
of the ability for this program to keep
CWD out of estate when you know um
captive herds that have been rolled in
programs and doing testing and not
finding positives um suddenly become
positive so that's you know those are
our concerns um we have importation
restrictions on CWD susceptible servid
there's there's virtually only one
served species that that you regularly
deal with which is phow deer that there
has been some experimental um infection
but it was the prons were essentially
injected directly into the brain stem
and even then it was difficult to infect
them so those that's a species that is
considered um really not susceptible to
C CWD we do allow those to be imported
um so again you know we we try and look
at what the current science is it's
constantly evolving um we do need to
evolve with that um but again right now
we feel that um requiring Hunters to
test their meat um is is somewhat
unnecessary given that it's still
considered meat as a low risk um for
spreading the disease thank you I'll
take questions are there any
questions representative Harvey so um I
hear you say low risk um how do you
determine when something is low medium
or high risk I mean when do we get cons
in the spectrum of things when does it
go from low yeah yeah that that's a good
question
um it's it's largely based off of
research um and there's there's been um
again there's no good answer to what an
infective dose of prons are um so
there's unfortunately there's no like
you know if you have this number of
prons in a tissue um you know that will
infect an animal um so so there is
there's not a great answer for that
other than
um other than the levels are so low in
these other tissues and it there's the
research to St has not suggested that
this is a transmission for um or this is
a this is
a um this is a route for transmission
into into
animals any other
questions represent
Stone how are you going to prevent
people from either State coming in the
state with meet from another state or a
country how you going to prevent that
and regulate it and what is it going to
cost
so it's not easy right um because
someone could easily drive through and
and you know go to their home and put
their meat in their freezer and we'll
we'll be none the wiser um that's
currently the case though with our
certain our current restrictions and we
do periodically um we do periodically
find people that have brought some of
these higher risk tissues into the state
um sometimes it's by accident be or Not
by accident but they weren't aware of
what the regulations were and our law
enforcement will work with those um in
those instances will'll confiscate those
those parts and we'll have them
incinerated or brought to a landfill um
but yeah it's an issue um sometimes you
know you hear from someone else that
they know of someone that brought
something in sometimes someone realizes
that they did something they weren't
supposed to and they contact us directly
to say oh I wasn't wasn't aware of this
and they self-report um but it's a good
question you know we can't have we can't
have um conservation officers at the
borders checking trucks for serving
meate from other states so it's going to
be pretty much impossible follow up
basically you know what I mean to try to
regulate this is going to you know you
can't stop every cover Tower and trck
comes in the state it it would be
difficult it
very any other
questions seeing none thank you for your
time today thank you seeing no other uh
speakers on this bill I will close the
hearing on HB 545
FN and I am opening the hearing on H
hb22 and the chair recognizes
representative Harvey Prime sponsor of
the
bill uh thank you Mr chair chairman and
thank you committee for giving me this
opportunity to present House Bill 202 um
I'm so lucky that I got to be the last
bill after a very long day you maybe
you'll remember me um I represent
chesher 6 which is Chesterfield Hinsdale
and um West
Morland um I I've been on the fishing
game committee for nine years now and um
as a member of the fishing game
committee I have attended many of
Fishing Game Commission meetings um the
only in fact in the nine years that I've
been there um I can tell you with great
certainty that myself representative
Jacobs and Representative Bob laroo are
pretty much the only ones that attend
those meetings uh the commission if if
you're not sure because you're new um
how it it's a um uh set up
the the commission has 11 members one
from each region of the state and the
11th is from the Sea Coast um underneath
them is the director of fishing game in
other words um 11 Commissioners oversee
the director of the
department I don't know of any other
organization that is set up this way
there's always one person at the top one
director one CEO one speaker of the
house one chairman of our committee um
one superintendent of schools Etc um and
all others work in consultation and in
advisory position to that um head of the
department not 11 people at the at the
department I can't imagine how that
would
work in the years that I've been
attending Fishing Game Commission
meetings I've noticed that this setup
has some inefficiency in it and that's
what prompted me to submit this bill um
I think it's kind of important that we
understand what this bill is not as well
as what this bill is uh first of all
this is not a partisan bill um I did
receive an email that said Commissioners
serve as a check and balance to a
politically appointed director uh who is
appointed by the governor but that isn't
really a balance because that is exactly
how the commissioner are appointed as
well they are nominated by Sportsman's
clubs they are appointed by the governor
and they're approved by the executive
committee the same way that the the
director is um
done and that was explained to us last
week when commissioner Kavanagh talked
about his interview process with the
executive
committee second of all this bill does
not suggest any change to the commission
it doesn't make any recommendation of
Hunter versus uh non-consumptive users
it doesn't make any change in the makeup
of the commission at all it's the same
commission the commission still would be
required to adhere to the North American
model of wildlife conservation which
we've heard talked about today and the
commission would still be absolutely
invaluable to the director in offering
guidance and
um
um advisement and guidance to the the
director of the um
Department this is a bill that would
provide some efficiency to the
department by setting the director as
head of the department and the cons uh
Commissioners as advisers and
Consultants um as I've attended these
meetings over the nine years I've seen
several missed opportunities that that
really would have benefited are
Sportsmen a great deal the Commissioners
meet uh once a month for usually about
two hours and they need to come to some
sort of majority agreement before an
action can take place that can be
sometimes a very slow process um and in
two areas it is a critically slow
process that have um provided missed
opportunities for our Sportsmen the
first is uh the acquisition of land and
water access um in the acquisition of
land and water access um a possible
acquisition is brought before the
commission uh before the 11 boards and
it's discussed invariably there's
questions that are ask and there should
be questions because sometimes there's
an expensive price tag with that
purchase um and then because there's
questions the a the action is tabled to
another month when there might be more
questions and then it's tabled to
questions and so forth um the director
does not have the power to enter into
even a
provisional um agreement with the person
who is offering the land in
2023 I watched 500 Acres of conservation
land be tabled for so long that the land
was eventually donated or sold to
another agency and this is land that our
hunters and our Anglers and our Trappers
could have been using for three years
but it was a missed opportunity because
the committee H by definition has to
work
slowly I've also um watched
opportunities for water access be lost
for the same reasons in 2012 um acre on
Alton Bay was lost uh the director had
no power to move forward with that and
um and so the commissions with without
the commission's
approval that was 14 years ago that our
boers and our swimmers and so forth
could have been using that land no new
beach has been purchased for 44 years by
fishing game and this has reached such a
crisis point that some towns like like
my own I live in Chesterfield like my
own have shut access off to anybody if
except those that live in the town
there's no room for additional Moorings
at many of our Lakes this is um this is
a problem that we need to if if the
opportunity comes we need to be able to
be more agile and to move more
efficiently to um to gather that uh to
take in that uh land acquisition and
water access uh funding as we've heard
today is another very deep concern um
the director right now has no power to
set fees except in consultation with the
commission um at the last Commission
meeting just last month um there was a
question about the RSA because it states
that the um fees can be set by the
director with
consultation with the Commissioners and
the Commissioners defined it that last
month as approval of the Commissioners I
personally think consultation and
approval are two different words but the
because of that definition that was set
just last month the director has no
authority to set fees uh there was
discussion about a dollar um charge for
a boat decal and the director was not
able to move forward with that um charge
and and this is at a time when funding
for fishing game is very crucial um
we'll be hearing some bills later on in
on the floor about taking money from
General funds for retirement and so
forth so um RSA 6 colon 10 actually
gives the commission the director the
authority to set findes in consultation
not necessarily with approval of the
commission and I believe if we lived up
to that
RSA uh funding crisis could be averted
in a much quicker manner she would have
the authority to B to to um manage and
um balance her own budget so um last
week we also learned that RSA 4-a sets
the duties of the fishing game
Commissioners they are to be stewards of
the fish and wildlife and Marine
Resources of our state through
conservation through longrange planning
through acquisition of public access to
land and Waters through public educ
and through uh proposing legislation all
this bill does is simply allow the
fishing game to fulfill its Duty and and
its mission statement which we also
heard last week um in a much more
efficient and agile way with the
consultation of the Commissioners thank
you thank you are there any
questions representative
Smith thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my
question um correct me if I'm wrong but
I understood that you stated that the
commission can't move fast enough to
make for example land Acquisitions there
have been times that they have not um
have they have had questions
and the motion had to be tabled until
the questions could be answered which
went on for at least three months in the
um one that I actually watched and the
family gave the lands to a different
agency follow up follow
up doesn't the commission have
flexibility via the chair to meet more
often if they determine the necessity to
meet to discuss these important matters
yes and that would be great but in my uh
nine years I've never seen that done
thank you any other
questions seeing none thank you for your
time today thank you Mr the chair calls
Welden Bosworth
thank you Mr chair again Welden Bosworth
from Guilford uh I did submit testimony
earlier I just want to emphasize a few
points here I won't take much of your
time the uh change proposed in this bill
I think will bring the Fish and Game
Commission and Department into line with
the best practices followed by a almost
all New Hampshire agencies and
departments and certainly with private
corporations where leadership is
streamlined for both efficiency and
accountability now when the current
structure of fishing game was first
developed back in 90 years ago in
1935 the geographic representation was
certainly a practical necessity since
with limited communication tools with uh
Commissioners from each County ensured
representation throughout the state
however now in 2025 with high
Communications virtual meet meetings and
online data readily available the
structure is no longer necessary in fact
it actively hinders
efficiency in my experience and I've
been a CEO of a medium-sized company and
also a chair of uh a couple of
organizations volunteer organizations
decision making by committee well one
well- intended introduces delays dilutes
accountability and creates unnecessary
bureaucratic
roadblocks so like things going around
here both locally and government uh
maybe the time for disruption is here
the idea that increases efficiency was
well
addressed by representative Harvey uh it
delay takes away the time that spent in
scheduling meetings debating and
securing consensus with multiple
individuals uh it it basically creates a
clear accountability which is very
timely right now with the uh budget
shortfall that's been almost perennial
who is accountable for that shortfall
wouldn't it be nice to point to one
person instead of this diffuse
organization this committee it also
prioritizes ability and expertise over
politics Commissioners are politically
appointed an executive director is
competitively selected through
interviews and the whole process of
finding the right person
so I think now is the time for New
Hampshire to modernize its approach on
the fish and game
department and I will take any
questions are there any
questions seeing none thank you for your
time
today the chair calls Eric stall from
The Fishing Game Commission
Mr chairman honorable members of this
wonderful committee my name is Eric
sto I live in the huge Metropolis of
Columbia New Hampshire and everybody
says where the heck is that and I say
well you know where C is yeah we're just
south of there I mov south from
Pittsburgh I was born and raised in
Pittsburgh but I move South to Walmer
climates I rise in opposition to House
Bill
202 uh I am a fishing game commissioner
representing Coos County I'm a retired
conservation officer with a little over
40 years
experience retiring at the rank of
Lieutenant The Fishing Game Commission
was established in
1869 with a duty as the citizens
representativ just like you folks
are to be stewards of the Fish Wildlife
and Marine Resources of the state of
Hampshire in addition to other duties
provided by law the commission was set
was to set General policy in the
following areas one conservation
protection and management of wildlife
populations and habitats the collection
of necessary scientific scientific
information and the enforcement of
fishing game laws for the purpose of
sustaining healthy population of fish
Wild Life and Marine Resources two
development and funding and
implementation of longrange strategic
plan to direct the operation of the fish
and gain Department matter of fact just
last evening we finished the latest uh
long range strategic Plan Three
acquisition development and maintenance
of public access to lands and Waters for
recreational use consistent with the
Hampshire law four public education and
building support for Department programs
and objective five establishment of
positions on proposed legislation that
affects Fish Wildlife Marine Resources
and the overall management of the fish
and gain department and six upon
petition and within 45 days of an appeal
request he appeals of decisions made by
the executive director to deny a permit
requested under RSA
20714 which deals with importation and
possession and selling a wildlife will
permit and the majority voted the Quorum
of the Commissioners reverse decision by
written ruling issued within 14 days of
the hearing the fishing gain Department
was established in
1935 RSA 2061 states there shall be an
agency of the state to be known
Hereafter as the fishing game department
under a commission to be known as The
Fishing Game Commission commissioner
Haron of Marat County and myself are the
longest serving Commissioners on the
present commission we were both
confirmed in
2017 this is the third or fourth time
that I have seen a similar Bill since
I've been on the commission which is
just short of 8 years this bill seeks to
change many rsas that have been in
practice for several years the process
that is in use today and has been for
many years is working just fine 1869 the
commission was created 1935 the fish and
gain Department was created under a
commission when I first joined the
commission in 20177 I remember one of my
first commission
meetings the the commission sets up in
front on a table I looked down the table
the commissioner where the Commissioners
were sitting and I noticed two
Commissioners sound
asleep how
embarrassing I I said to myself what am
I getting into I assure you that that is
not the case of the commission today it
appears to me the sponsors feel that the
fishing game Commissioners that are
serving today are not the best during my
tenure on the commission I have
witnessed a major
change in the caliber of Commissioners
the education of Commissioners in recent
times is amazing the education degrees
that consists of Forestry Wildlife
Management International Affairs geology
hydrology accounting business management
civil engineering criminal justice
microbiology we have two saltwater
commercial fishermen on the commission
as well we police our own there is an
RSA that states no member of the fishing
gain commission may be engaged or
involved in any Personnel matters of the
department including the hiring
discipline disciplining firing promoting
evaluating transferring and any other
matters associated with the certified
employees of the department goes on to
say that if a complaint is made against
a commissioner there shall be a hearing
we recently just had one such hearing I
think I told you this last week when I
was in front of you with the assistance
of the Attorney General's office it was
determined that the commissioner did in
fact violate the law we recommended to
the governor and counsel which is the
process that the commissioner be removed
prior to that the commissioner did
resign during our commission meeting we
set aside time on the in the agenda to
the hearing of the public some of the
time we are hearing from individuals
that disagree with the work at our
professional biologist like Dan oh I
just Dan left
uh disagree with some of the work of our
professional biolog some disagree with
some of the positions the commission has
taken on these issues most compliment
the commission and the department for
doing the job as well as they do this
year we had 109 lsis and you all know
that's what it is before they get the
body of the of the language that we were
tracking uh what we do is we meet with
with staff we go over each individual
one when the language comes out we
develop well we're going to support it
we're going to and and the commission
nine times out of 10 if this year it's
been 10 times out of 10 we totally agree
with what the staff says on
recommendations on the
bills uh some of the individuals that
speak and write to us I honestly believe
are preservationists not
conservationists they do not believe in
killing anything one of the best or
sometimes the only tool you have is
harvest in the excess of a particular
Wildlife if this isn't done the habitat
will be damaged and mother nature will
call call out the excess and it won't be
pretty again I am opposed to House Bill
202 and I thank you for your time and
I'll try to answer any question you
might have thank you so much for your
time are there any
questions seeing none thank you for your
time
today chair calls Ray Green
thank you Mr
chairman the commission my name is Ray
green I'm from mord I am also the
fishing game commissioner for hillsbro
County which is the largest county in
the state of New
Hampshire I am also chairman of the
fishing Game
Commission I
strongly oppose this
bill I'm not going to get into all the
statis yeah
statistics like commissioner SPO did but
I want to bring out a few
points this bill is to take away all the
authorities of the commission it is to
make the commission advisory
only and that's it advisory
only we've heard the history of the
commission we've heard what the
commission does and now what this bill
wants to
do Mr bodsworth used the word that I'm
going to say he hit it the nail on the
head
destruct he wants to destruct
The Fishing Game Commission which will
also affect the fishing game
department if this Fishing Game
Commission goes to advisory only it's
like in a past bill that I had said
you're leaving it up to one person the
director that will be in charge of
everything to do with fishing game in
the wildlife in the state of New
Hampshire and to put it into a little
bit more
re more into something we can all
understand everybody in this room that
is a representative I'm sure you became
a
representative you wanted to M make
things better you wanted to make an
impact and that's why you ran as a
representative my question is would you
be a representative if you're only
advisor and now other words advisory
means I'll give you my opinion but you
don't have to listen to
it Commissioners are the same
way I can honestly sit here and say if
this commission went
advisory I'll be the first one to walk
over that governor's office and resign I
find it had every day when I get up why
am I even being a commissioner for the
amount of time the involvement the
heartache the stress that goes into it
and you want to take
away and make us just
advisory we have a hard time finding
Commissioners because a lot of
Commissioners I mean people out in the
public are starting to realize how much
work a commissioner gets involved in how
much work and dedication it takes to be
a commissioner if you turn around and
make this advisory only I don't know
anybody that would want to do
it and by not having the commission
you're not going to have your voices
heard you right now can go to your
county commissioner with any type of
problem suggestions ideas or
whatever you can go to that commissioner
and that commissioner should be bringing
it along to the full commission and to
fish and
game you will lose that right as a
person in this state that you now don't
have an Avenue directly to fishing
game I I I
know representative Reed has sit there
and talked about land that sometimes
land has taken up a lot of time yes it
has because sometimes land has been been
presented to us we don't even know if
there's a clear title to it we don't
know if there's hazardous materials on
it there are people that are willing to
donate their land so they get out of a
hazardous material situation yes the the
commission takes their time on some
pieces of land to make sure
that the state is not getting a
hazardous material site or something
that's going to bite us down the
road we cannot keep everybody happy
people will come in and say the
commission never listens to
us I talk to
everybody the people that complain about
the commission are the ones that don't
get their way
the ones that come in and say I want
trapping
outlawed we don't Outlaw it no the
commission doesn't listen they don't
listen to
us and I'm going to give you a perfect
example of how the
commission with fishing game works
because you had dealt with this last
week was a poaching bill and I hate to
throw a pass director under the bus but
I want you to understand how this
commission Works two years ago we
brought up about poaching that something
had to be done all we did was give the
idea fishing game do something about
this a year went
by nothing was
done and if you look on that bill it'll
say that bill was started by the
commission because a commission had said
fishing game you didn't do anything
about it we are and we started the
bill and that's the bill you received
last
week and if you want to make this
commission like I
say advisory
only I know you wouldn't be a rep if you
were advisory only good luck in finding
Commissioners I'm open to there any
questions I'm very hot about this
subject Mr chair I know I can't ask ask
a question and that's okay but he um
mistakenly um attributed the bill to
representative Reed I want to make sure
that everybody's clear that um it's
represent clarified thank you
yes representative
ulette we heard uh testimonial a while
ago saying it's very difficult to run a
company by a board by a commission and I
kind of picture it as that the director
runs the day-to-day but the commissioner
is like the board of directors Who
overseas sets policy and runs it is that
a correct that is 100% correct thank the
director does the daytoday operation The
Fishing Game Commission is the overall
operation of fishing game thank you any
further
questions seeing none thank you for your
time
I will tell the committee that I've been
told by leadership we have a hard stop
at
5 we can't go past
then I now call Randy ulette from the
New Hampshire guides
Association good afternoon uh my name is
Randy wette from Tamworth New Hampshire
I'm a licensed New Hampshire guide a
guide outfitter for White Mountains
National Forest
um we are opposed to this Bill
wholeheartedly um there's not a lot I
can actually add beyond our two
Commissioners what they said so I'm just
going to read a quick snippet um from
our prepared testimony just to share
with you to reinforce that if that's
okay uh we feel that eliminating this
system of this system of Citizen
Commissioners working in tandem with our
executive director to better serve the
needs of our respective constituents and
ensure the sustainability and
accessibility of our natural resources
would be very ill advised our
commissioners advocate for their
specific counties needs to New Hampshire
fishing game with commissions current
the commission's current Authority they
can ensure those needs are being met
real time the commiss Commissioners
thoughtfully and ethically represent the
diverse interests of their constituents
the needs and concerns of these areas
can differ greatly from one end of the
state to the other New Hampshire fishing
Game Commission brings years of
collective institutional knowledge in
addition to providing a real-time input
as to where New Hampshire's outdoor
Community stands in critical issues
within their specific County and the
state in general we believe the New
Hampshire fishing game commission's
consent is needed now more than ever for
decision related to long-term planning
and preservation of our state's
resources I'd like to close with a quick
back to high school history lesson it
just kind of struck me a good friend of
mine is also a guide out in Montana I
thought thought this is worth sharing
power must never be trusted without a
check and I wholeheartedly agree as a
small business owner you have to have an
executive director and a board of
directors they work in concert not one
above another thank you very much thank
you are there any questions seeing none
thank you very much chair call last
speaker Kyle
Baker thank you uh for the last time
today I'm Kyle Baker Rath young and
pelli here on behalf of the New
Hampshire Wildlife Federation I'm
handing out two pieces of testimony just
from two folks that weren't able to make
it this afternoon one is from Fred bird
and the Congressional Sportsman's
foundation and another one is from a son
of one of the New Hampshire wildlife
federation's board members who's a
student studying Wildlife Conservation
um who wanted to be here today but is at
school so uh also submitted some
comments um so the natur Wildlife
Federation is opposed to this bill um we
see the commission as an incredibly
integral part of the conservation Pro
process in New Hampshire um
Commissioners are those that are in the
communities engaging day-to-day with the
folks on the ground that are whether
you're Hunting Fishing trapping or just
enjoying the outdoors uh they are your
your first point of contact in to the
department um we also have a lot of you
know we support uh a
rigorous process when it comes to
spending funds that are gathered through
user fees at the department um when it
takes a while for the fishing Game
Commission a number of months to move on
a piece of land um they're doing that
because they're spending money that was
directly collected from user fees in New
Hampshire um whether it's Pitman
Robertson dollars or Dingle Johnson
dollars or habitat fees or conservation
fees uh they're doing their due
diligence to in spending the money like
it's their own uh which New Hampshire
Sportsman greatly greatly appreciate um
everything else that I want to say has
already been said so I'll leave it at
that but happy to answer any
questions thank you are there any
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony
today that closes the public hearing on
hb22 now we will Mo move forward on the
um
HB it's a uh excuse me the uh Amendment
d63 2hb 655 FN relative fishing game
violations and this is a um non gerain
Amendment that's going with it and I
turn the floor over to Chairman
Spain thank you as you all know we heard
the uh the bill that uh accompanies this
655 FN which is a housekeeping bill
regarding restitution costs and and uh
penalties for poaching uh last week but
this amendment to that to include in the
housekeeping as one General housekeeping
bill was ruled non- gerain so it has to
have its own public hearing this bill is
being introduced because we ran into a
situation uh where we have a constituent
who many years ago many many years ago
injured his shoulder and uh got a
crossbow license for his his hunting
uh permanently
disabled and medical science has
progressed to the point where he was
able to received treatment fixed his
shoulder completely and he was cleared
to go back to hunting with his regular
bow but when he approached the
department the administrative staff at
the department um said that he could not
have a regular bow hunting license that
he was stuck using a crossbow license
forever and ever because in the law it
said in
perpetuity and talked to Colonel Jordan
about this and I said that's not how
this is supposed to work the permanent
part was just supposed to mean he didn't
have to come back every year and prove
he was still disabled but if we always
hope people get better we always hope
that they can go back to using their
regular bow if they if they get better
um and we both agreed on that but the
staff said there's nothing we can do we
can't issue him his regular hunting
license for his bow
anymore so we now want to put this
amendment through that will strike out
the part that says the crossbow permit
shall be
perpetual and that will allow the staff
to allow somebody who gets better to go
back to hunting with the regular bow and
not be stuck with their crossbow license
at all times and I'll take any
questions any
questions yes sir I think you're
right you know that's what I want to say
you heard you I think you're right thank
you I think we should pull it and back
up the ra back to fish gain Department
with resources they
need any other questions for uh chairman
Spain thank you very much thank
you that should conclude our hearings
for today when the chairman returns
we'll see where he wants to go from here
hearing on the non- Germain amendment is
closed we have uh multiple bills that we
could do some quick execs on we have uh
about 25 minutes and we've got to be out
of here um I would like to do some execs
and get them out of the way if that's
possible we might even be able to get
them all done uh yes representative
Harvey
um yes maybe yes maybe no
um I just don't want us to get into um
you know a heavy discussion about
something and it gets to be five o'clock
and we have to leave I I'd rather you
know us to be able to finish our
discussion completely and and not carry
that forward and have to exec you know
later on so just be mindful maybe of um
if it's a bill that is going to seems to
be requiring some um argument or
discussion or whatever that it might not
be the best to take up right now
understood why don't we take up uh
initially the fact that I'm going to
offer this amendment onto 655 and if we
open up the exec session on 655 we could
open we could open with this non-gain
amendment and put that right on to that
uh
it's sorry would that be okay with you
that would be fine I also had had that
simple amendment that changed the dollar
amount too we can talk about that at the
same time okay I'm going to open the ex
ex session on HB
655 I would take a motion on
655 move to pass on
655 Tudor moves ought to pass and is
that seconded second seconded from Mike
goulette um it's now open for Amendment
and I offer Amendment 2025 00 63h which
we've just had our public hearing
on I think I've said everything that
everybody needs to know about this
amendment I think it's the right thing
to do and uh so did Colonel Jordan
um I would open any uh I would I would
actually like to move that we have uh we
accept the
amendment and uh ready for motion Mr
believe I need a second and
representative Durk and you had said you
would second that not is that not
correct all right so it's been moved and
seconded we can have discussion on on
this amendment now if anybody wants to
have any discussion on the
amendment if there's none I'll just have
the clerk call the role and we'll get
that over
with clerk may call the
role Mr chairman yes Mr Vice chairman
yes representative Smith
yes representative tutor yes represent
Murphy yes representative Aldrich yes
representative derkin yes clerk votes
yes representative Harvey yes
representative Fox yes representative
Jacobs yes representative oor yes
representative Pearson
yes representative Stone
yes it's 14 yeses 14 to
[Music]
that makes it otpa at the moment the
bill is open to further amendments if
anybody wants to offer a further
Amendment um I would like to offer an
amendment um
0299 which simply changes the um um
violation fee for Fisher Bobcat otter
and fox from $200 to $1,000 and I have
um it was 500 in the original bill but
this raises it to a th000 and I have
copies of this amendment pass them
around and do you have a second if
you're moving
that okay it's been moved and seconded
by rep Fox it's open for
discussion I I can address that soon as
you hand those over you feel free to
discuss that so so my my reason for the
for just changing that one line in the
bill um is is very simple um um of all
the animals and and wild of all the
wildlife that was listed in there uh
Fisher is one of
um is is being decimated we heard last
week that UNH has actually started a
study to see why we're losing our Fisher
um population it could be um because of
rodenticides we don't know but they've
started um UNH has a a study going to
see what has happened to our Fisher Fox
is the same way you saw a graph this
morning the number of fox are are going
down so so if something happens to those
particular animals um it is much more
harmful and detrimental to our Wildlife
than if something is happens to a
squirrel or a turkey and so I I just I
think that because those are so not
they're not on an endangered list but
because they're so critical the fine for
that should be more than it was
originally so I um I'm offering this
amend mment to raise that fine to
$1,000 for any any further discussion
representative
tutor thank you Mr chair I uh I oppose
this amendment um this bill is about
restitution and it should be about the
cost of basically replacing the animal
if you if you wanted to or had to and to
put a uh Fisher at the same level as a
deer moose uh just doesn't seem right to
me any further discussion representative
Stone
I think she's right I I I addressed this
a week ago about $1,000 2,000 you got to
do something to make them think twice if
you don't do it they're going to keep on
doing it I agree with a
$1,000 I would go more if we
could any further discussion rep oh
representative ulette uh thank you Mr
chair uh I again I I will disagree with
with u representative Harvey just for
the simple reason that our friends at
fishing gam set these limits on what the
value was and they were very very clear
last week that when they're talking
about law enforcement it's never
punitive it's all educational and this
is supposed to be replacement cost of
the
animal representative Harvey so I'm
confused how we um uh replace an animal
once it's once it's dead it's dead um so
and because these two animals Fisher and
fox are so their populations are so down
it it would be even harder then to
replace those animal so I'll add on to
that replacement cost of the animal is
done the same way essentially we
repopulated our turkeys in that instance
we didn't pay money but we traded uh
what was it Fishers Fishers for turkeys
and we repopulated our turkeys from zero
in the state by bringing in turkeys from
another state and trading them some of
our
Fishers um but in some instances the
state will actually have to purchase
those animals to repopulate a population
and that's what the the uh cost is
supposed to uh capture is is the
restitution to the state for the value
of the animal that was killed in case
the state needed to replace that animal
am I correct Colonel Jordan thank you uh
are there any other
comments
see um yes representative Jacobs thank
you I think we've heard a few times
today that the Fisher population is in
danger so I feel like it makes sense to
raise the fine especially if we're
looking at a dwindling population I
mean yeah I feel it's reasonable thank
you I'll add on that it's not a fine
it's a
restitution um it's supposed to capture
the value of a Fisher Colonel Jordan do
we have any actual figures on what it
would cost us to buy a Fisher or a
population of fishers from another state
not that I'm aware of I mean if I had
had time I could have asked Brad to find
that for us and I'm sure that he could
have found that within about uh a day
but uh the only issue I can see at
creating if we go as high as a large
SP it will cause some confusion with our
judges so we'd have to explain to the
judges why we're getting ,000 for a
Fisher and five I think it's $500 for a
light that would that would create some
discussion in the courtroom which you
know makes me nervous open the door for
a judge thank you I understand I
understand representa it's a blurry line
between fine and restitution right um
so any any other comments
questions seeing
none
um do we have a I do I do okay
representative
DeVito I was to with if I was going to
say something
um I feel like this really is bluring
the line between emotion and facts um of
what the animal's life is worth who is
to say that a squirrel or a red fox or
something else their life is worth more
than a deer or vice versa so if we're
talking
about a monetary value of an animal's
life then why isn't it
the same number across the
board why are we putting more on a
Fisher and I understand we're saying
they're in danger um but that could
happen with any animal and so I I in my
mind I can't wrap my mind around saying
$1,000 for a Fisher
yet a fox is is less than that or any
other
animal representative Harvey
so if you're making a motion that we
amend the bill so that all the animals
are
$1,000 I I'm okay with
that okay we have a motion on the floor
of ought to pass because the the
amendment was moved and
seconded that is the current motion and
we will call the role on ought to pass
and see what the the role comes
through this is a roll call on the ought
to pass for Amendment 0299 H correct
okay Mr chairman no Mr Vice chairman
no Mr Smith no Mr tutor no Mr Murphy no
Mr Aldrich no Mr Durkin no clerk votes
no Miss Harvey yes
Mr Fox
yes Mr love
it oh
hello Miss
Jacobs
yes Mr
no Mr Pearson
yes Mr Stone
yes that's five
yeses and 10 Nos and five the amendment
fail sorry the amendment fails we're on
otpa on the original
bill and if there's no further
discussion we'll call the rooll on the
original Bill
otpa Mr chairman yes Mr Vice
chairman yes representative Smith yes
representative tutor yes represent
Murphy yes representative Aldrich yes
representative Durkin
yes clerk votes yes Miss Harvey yes
representative Harvey I'm sorry I
apologize representative Fox yes
representative lit oh again I need to
mark that um representative Jacobs yes
representative oor yes representative
Pearson yes representative Stone yes
any objections any objections to
consent seeing none that'll go on
consent and as the person who made the
motion on the original otpa that would
be representative tutor you owe me a
blurb on
that it was uh 14 to
Z we may have time for one more uh given
that we have some that have an early
deadline to another committee we might
as well hear uh hb5 oh this closes the
executive session on HB 655 FN I will
now open the executive session on HB 573
FNA relative to the funding for search
and rescue operations of the fish and
game department and making a an
appropriation here to for and I
recognize representative Harvey for a
motion um I would motion I make a motion
that we itl this bill
do I have a
second representative
Pearson and would you like me to speak
to you may speak to that now yes um so
you know as as much as I would love to
fund search and rescue to the hilt um we
heard testimony today that um uh it this
price tag is 200,000 and it would be
200,000 every year um which may build
build up to quite a large sum of money
um if it's if it's not used um and then
we heard testimony from Colonel Jordan
that says right now they're in pretty
good shape so it it would be very
difficult for me to look at a
constituent and say yes we gave them
$200,000 even though they said they
didn't need it um it it just is would be
tough in a tight budget year so um I
would vote to itl this bill thank you is
there any further
discussion clerk may call the
role Mr chairman yes Mr Vice chairman
yes representative Smith yes
representative tutor yes representative
Murphy yes representative
Aldrich
yes representative Durkin
yes clerk votes yes representative
Harvey yes sorry yes representative Fox
yes representative Jacobs yes
representative oor yes representative
Pearson yes representative Stone yes 14
yeses all right uh any objection to
consent seeing none uh do you need a
blur then for that I do need it because
if it gets pulled from consent we need
to have it okay uh it's very simple yeah
I know um done it before and with that I
will leave the last three bills for exec
on another time and in fact if I get up
on the floor tomorrow during
session I we can exec during lunch or
something else and get some more of
these done tomorrow rather than have
everybody come in here for one day for
three bills so uh that is an option that
I can use tomorrow as long as we do it
from the house floor I can announce that
exec session tomorrow can I eat my lunch
while we exec we would exec somewhere
other than this room so that we could do
so I have two things for 589 that I need
to pass off to this okay uh that closes
the the uh exec session on 573 FN and it
ends
our uh committee hearings for the day
thank you all I'll see you tomorrow in
session and uh there are some things
that the clerk needs to get to everybody
y yeah